Musik Also machst du mal bequem.
Da ist das Mikrofon.
Sehr gerne.
Man sieht, alles ist schon ein bisschen amateurhaft.
Ja, weil in der Hand heilig ist, ist natürlich cool.
Weil wir sonst eigentlich vor Skype immer aufnehmen.
Wir können auch so ausspringen zwischendurch, wenn ich mich anschwellig bin.
Ja, wenn ich solo dann können wir da ausspringen.
Nee, da ist es dann in Ordnung.
Hast du dir wahrscheinlich ein bisschen anders vorgestellt, die grosse, weite BTF, die Produktionshimmel, aber wir sind ja nur so das kleine Krebsgeschwür, das nicht tödliche Krebsgeschwür. Das ungewollte, die ungewollten Kinder, die irgendwie ein Podcastprojekt nebenbei am laufen haben. Ja genau, das ist das Schulprogramm. Aber laufen wir schon? Wir laufen schon. Wir laufen so nebenbei ein bisschen. Ach so, echt? Ihr habt das erst an. Das ist so ein altercaster-Trick, dass man erst so ein ganz authentisches, natürliches Gespräch vorne wegfällt. Das Pre-Gespräch, das habe ich aber jetzt kaputt gemacht. Ich hätte ausführlich auf angedrückt, wenn das ein Trick war von dir, Respekt, aber ich habe einfach nur ausversehlich draufgekommen. Man sieht, dass der Gast auch irgendwie ein ganz natürlicher, normaler Mensch ist und nicht dann irgendwie, sobald die Mikrofone angehen, dann anfängt zu performen. Aber ich habe schon automatisch angefangen zu lächeln. Ja, das ist so das Show-Lächeln, was man so festgetagert hat. Die Webkehr macht fünfzehn Minuten ein Foto, ne? Also von daher, ich glaube, in drei Minuten ist es wieder so weit. Ach so, ich bin schauspielerisch so gut, dass ich da auch hingeguckt habe jetzt. Es geht mir jedes Mal in das Neue. Ich such's hier auch noch, ne? Die Technik ist so ein bisschen zurückgeblieben hier. Von daher, alles in Ordnung. Hast du mal einen Podcast gehört von uns? Ich habe den tatsächlich fast komplett, ist es gerade eine E-Mail reingekommen? Ja, das ist unser Ding, das sind die Geräusche nebenbei. Warnung zu luken, was ist das? Das ist so viel Spam-Scheisse, was bei dir immer kommt. Also vorneweg diesen Energy Drink, auch wenn er... Booster, boost your Gags. Also vom Design sieht es wirklich sehr... Gefährlich aus, das spielen die so ein bisschen. Es sieht nicht besonders dynamisch aus. Es ist dynamisch. Die wollen so eine Erfahrung daraus machen, glaube ich, so ein ganzes Erlebnis. Es ist so ein bisschen osteuropäisch. Ja, sehr. Was man beim Norma für 19 Cent kann. Norma? Ist es jetzt Norma noch? Es ist Norma, ja. Norma. Und wie hieß das mit den kleinen Preisen früher? Penny, nee, plus die kleinen Preise. Da hatte ich sogar ein Kuscheltier, so eine Eins oder eine 90 hatte ich als Kuscheltier. Weil die hatten so eine Kampagne, wo die Preise dann irgendwo runterstürzen oder so, so wie Lemminge sich irgendwie in die Grube werfen, die Preise stürzen. Die Preise stürzen einfach. Ich glaube, die war von Stefan, die Kampagne. Ja, genau. Der alte Werbetexte. Ja, ich habe einen Podcast von euch gehört, um noch auf die Frage zurückzukommen, und zwar den letzten, weil ich angetweetet wurde mit dem Ad Luke Mockridge wurde ich angetweetet. Echt? Weil irgendjemand, ich glaube, du weißt das, Stefan, ein Bekenntnis zu mir gemacht hast, oder so? Ach so, da war ich, ich wurde interviewt, glaube ich, irgendwo, ich wurde interviewt. Ist mir das zum ersten Mal passiert? Ach, ich dachte, das war dieser Podcast. Ne, ne, das war ein, du hast einen falschen Podcast gehört. Ja, dann habe ich euch tatsächlich noch gar nicht gehört. Das ist gut, das ist sehr gut. Sehr gut. Hey, cool, der macht sich, der macht sich den Gast die Mühe, unseren Podcast zu hören. Das ist der Falsche. Du bist fast so gut vorbereitet wie wir. Das ist natürlich sehr peinlich. Wir haben auch noch nie einen Podcast von uns gehört. Aber dann seid ihr nicht das Podcast-Ufo, dann war es ... Doch, das sind wir. Nein, wir sind gestern diese Geister waren. Was habe ich denn dann gehört? Radio Nucolas wahrscheinlich gehört. Nee, du hast eigentlich ein Studentenradio gehört, wo ich interviewt wurde. Letztes Jahr ... ja. Um 1994. Du hast vielleicht telefoniert mit Joyce oder so, vielleicht hast du es einfach verwechselt mit dem Podcast. Das machen wir nie. Wir skypen nur nackt. Wir werden gerade angeguckt von gegenüber. Ist dir das gerade hier? Das ist sehr interessant. Aber das bist du ja mittlerweile gewohnt wahrscheinlich, oder? Dass einfach überall, wenn in jedem Raum, wo du bist, einfach an der anderen Seite, an der Schwarzseite die Ferngläser gespitzt werden, sowas in der Richtung. Das ist alles so ein bisschen so Hinterhof-Flair hier, ne? Aber ich finde es cool, es ist ja Ehrenfeld. Ehrenfeld ist ja so ein bisschen der Berliner Stadtteil von Köln. Also Köln ist ja sehr provinziell noch und Ehrenfeld ist so versucht Prenzelberg, Mitte und Kreuzberg und Neukölln. Aber man schafft es nicht ganz. Ehrenfeld ist Neukölln. Das ist doch ein schöner Satz, ne? Ah, verstehe. Wir sind sehr langsam, es tut mir leid. Ja, sehr gut sehr gut. Nicht schlecht, du. Ich stehe noch im Booster, damit meine Gäste aufkommen. Booster Jokes. Ich habe den Podcast mit Maxi Geständen beantwortet, das habe ich ein bisschen reingehört. Das ist so ein bisschen, wir wollen da ganz ehrlich sein, wir sind ein ehrlicher, transparenter Podcast, wir sind offen. Das war so ein bisschen unser Rockbottom in einer gewissen Weise, weil wir tun uns tatsächlich immer sehr schwer mit Gästen. Stefan und ich, wir sind gute Freunde, wir kennen uns aus dem Kindergarten. Ihr habt so einen eigenen Banta. Es ist so ein bisschen Insidermäßig, wir kennen so die ganzen Insider so. Das Ding ist, wir hatten drei Gäste bislang. Der erste war Oli P., der ein Fan von dem Podcast ist, das heißt, der wusste ungefähr, worauf er sich einlässt. Aber wenn er der erste Gast war, dann war er Fan von einem Podcast, den es bis dato noch ganz gab. Das ist Oli P. Daran musst du dich gewöhnen mit Oli P. Du hast ständig solche What-Momente bei Oli P. Wow, wie ist ein Raumzeitkontinuum in seinem Bauch und fährt mit den Flugzeugen dadurch. Oli P. hat auch erzählt, dass wenn ein Hund einen anderen Hund tötet, das erste, was er isst, ist dessen Mageninhalt. Der isst das, was der Beutehund gefressen hat. Hat er das in unserer Folge erzählt. Das hat er in unserer Folge, da habe ich es nie gehört. Der ist ja auch Hundeprofi, ne? Ja, genau. Er liebt Hunde. Ich glaube, es ist auch sogar Liebe deinen Hund. Das ist, glaube ich, ein Buch, was er jetzt rausgebracht hat. Der hat tatsächlich das geschafft, was sie wenigstens... Genau, so ein Saarlandbuch, glaube ich, kommt sehr gut an. Oh, oh, oh, oh. Der hast du aber heute noch mal in Jans Orta geguckt. Du, ich weiss nicht, alles ist möglich heute. Aber der hat tatsächlich diesen Schritt geschafft, die nur weniger 90er-Stars schaffen, einfach von den 90er-Stars, von den Charts, ins Podcast-Ufo, ins Podcast-Ufo, in das Hunde-Business dann letztendlich. Nee, und deswegen, aber Max, wie hast du es denn gesehen? Also als jemand, der gar nichts von uns jemals gehört hat, wie war das für dich? Es war ein bisschen, also ich mag ja Maxi, aber Maxi ist auch ein sehr, also ein fantastischer Comedian, aber auch ein sehr eigener Kopf und nicht der nahbarste Mensch. Aber das ist bei vielen Comedians natürlich der Fall. Bei dir auch so. Sehr gut, eine perspektive Frage. Bist du nahbar? Das ist auch so ein Podcast-Ding, dass man das, wenn eine Behauptung aufgestellt wird, des Gastes, man das als Frage zurückstellt. Genau, direkt auf den Gast beziehen. Schön, schön. Ob ich nahbar bin, kann man selber, glaube ich, gar nicht beantworten. Das muss aber andere über einen sagen. Wir haben uns ja kennengelernt in einer Aftershow-Party von den Videodays. Und das war auch eine grosse Überwindung, dich anzusprechen. Da war ich sehr nahebar. Ja, vor allem, du hast... Du standest direkt vorm Toilettenhäuschen und hast da so ein bisschen den Eingang versperrt, was ich einen ganz coolen Move fand. Irgendwie, das war einfach so geil. Du merkst, es gibt so verschiedene Hotspots an Partys. Weißt du, die einen sind am DJ-Pult, die anderen sind so meine Frauen. In der Küche ist immer die politische Diskussion. In der Küche wird immer über Politik geredet. Man kann sich warum. Und auch so die Kennste-Noch-Diskussion. Kennste doch die Turtles oder kennste noch Salomon? Das ist immer in der Küche. Da habe ich meine komplette Karriere drauf aufgebaut auf diesem Moment. Kennst du noch die Lücks-Beris? Cool, oder? Sag mal, wir hätten dich, als du in die Einfahrt reingekommen bist, fast nicht erkannt, weil du ein T-Shirt anhattest. Das war der zweite Gag, den ich mir vorbereitet habe. Wie glaube ich denn sonst rum? Weil du oft nackt bist. Das ist tatsächlich sehr… Kinder, Leute, kommen dir gar nichts zurück. Ich habe einen einzigen Gag über. Ich beobachte ganz gespannt. Boah, Jesus. Das stimmt. Ich bin sehr oft in vielen Sendungen nackt. Warum? ZDF sag ich schon, Sat.1 will von dir, dass du nackt bist. Will Arte das von dir. Wen hat Sat.1 denn noch unter Vertrag? Schwarz, Rot, Pink. Ah, mhm. Ich hab den nackten Vertrag, ich hab den gleichen Vertrag wie Taylor Lautner bei Twilight. Weniger Geld dafür. Scheiss auf Dialog, wenn der Dialog haben, dann einfach scherlte vom Leib reissen. Ich glaube, das ist meine exhibitionistische Ader, die, ich glaube, jeder Comedian oder jede Person des öffentlichen Lebens auch ein bisschen hat, dass man sich nackt gerne zeigt und einfach ins Rampenlicht geht, ohne irgendwas. Und ich glaube, das ist einfach das, was in mir drinsteckt, nach aussen getragen. Also wirklich exhibitionistisch. Aber auf den Video-Days, Nachhinein darauf zurückzukommen, hattest du was an? Habe ich gesehen, das ist ein Video gesehen. Es gibt ein Video, was wir euch niemals zeigen werden. Was mega absurd ist. Ja, es ist sehr peinlich. Es ist extrem peinlich. Nein, es ist sehr peinlich. Es ist sehr peinlich. Aber es ist eine total unangenehme Veranstaltung, weil im Hintergrund auch immer so viel laut oder irgendwie von Y-Titty plötzlich rumkommen und irgendwie die Kamera. Die Lochens waren da. Es ist alles die Kamera geil. Das war eine ganz schlechte Folge Promi-Dinner. Aber es ist ja schön, sich manchmal in so ganz schwachen Momenten zu sehen. Das ist so wie, wenn du dich selber dabei anschauen könntest, wie du versuchst, eine Frau anzusprechen. Und diese zwölf Tanzschritte, bevor du es machst, so dir anzusehen, das ist nochmal so ein ganzer Schwachpunkt. Genau diese Tanzschritte hatte ich von mir auf Band, als ich dich versucht habe anzusprechen. Es ist für uns beide peinlich. Es ist auf jeden Fall für jeden Video peinlich. Es ist für jeden Anwesen peinlich. Nur für Laune kommt gut weg. Für Laune kommt mega gut weg. Oskar Reif kommt er weg, auch mega besoffen. Aber es ist eine unangenehme Veranstaltung einfach, weil jeder anscheinend Kamera geil ist. Also bei jeder... Ach, bei einem YouTube-Event. Die sehen die Kamera und alle laufen dahin. Aber es war tatsächlich... Meine Strategie war, ich habe mich neben dich gestellt, neben meine coole Crew von coolen Jungs und deine Posse, wo du dich cool unterhalten hast. Und ich habe mich einfach daneben gestellt. Und meine Strategie war einfach, ich warte so lange, bis ich angesprochen werde. Du hast mich im Gespräch gelacht. Ich habe mich ins Gespräch mit reingelacht. Und ich habe auf deinen Narzissmus ein bisschen gehofft, dass wenn du siehst, okay, da lacht jemand, den hole ich rein, so der ist gut, den brauche ich in meinem Leben. Habe ich das gemacht? Du hast es gemacht, ja. Ich bin tatsächlich aber auch jemand, ich kann, ich hasse Partys, also deswegen besaufe ich mich auf Partys, weil ich habe totale Sozialprobleme, also ich kann das nicht. Kennt ihr das, wenn du auf einer Party bist und einer kommt nicht ins Gespräch rein oder nur zwei unterhalten sich, der dritte steht da nur und geht dann irgendwann weg, ohne was zu sagen. Es ist so unangenehm. Boah, das ist so awkward. Oder versucht ein Gespräch anzufangen, aber die anderen sprechen anders weiter und er hört auf und hört dann einfach auf und spricht nie wieder an. Und einer guckt ihn an und merkt, entscheidet sich dann doch wieder, was alles passiert, zurückzuschwächen. Boah, das ist so einfach ganz klar. Nein, das ist jetzt gerade hier passiert, weil du wolltest gerade genau das tun. Ich kann aber nicht gehen, weil der Raum ist nicht zu. Ja, gut, wir sind hier in einem gefangenen Raum, er muss früher oder später gehört werden. Also er hat es da relativ einfach. Awkward moments. Aber es ist tatsächlich schön, weil es gibt Menschen, die sind da wahnsinnig aufmerksam dafür. Gerade Gatt und Comedian ist dafür prädestiniert, dass dir solche Dinge auffallen, weil es ist ein Job. Aber von dir denkt man das nicht, von dir denkt man das nicht, als du so was hast. Ich kann nicht mir vorstellen, dass ich wahrscheinlich auch wirke wie jemand, der manchmal vielleicht ein bisschen über den Ding und hey cool und ich bin in Medien und so. Aber tatsächlich bin ich in total, auch durch, ich habe fünf Brüder, ich bin sehr katholisch erzogen worden, also ich bin eigentlich. Aber das ist ja oft so, dass man aus so einem Defizit heraus, aus so einem Sozialdefizit heraus, irgendwie auch so eine Rampensau-Attitüde entwickeltkeln. Genau, das ist so ein Jetzt-oder-nie-Moment. Cool, wir haben dich jetzt schon durchschaut. In Minute zehn haben wir das Rätselig mausisch gelöst. Ja, aber man lernt ja durch Aussenseiterrollen auch einfach gewisse Dinge vorzutäuschen, eine Maske aufzusetzen und kann das dann natürlich auch im künstlerischen Rahmen umsetzen. Und man muss natürlich wesentlich aufmerksamer sein. Wenn du der Underdog bist, musst du genau gucken, was machen die Leute, wie kriegen sie Lacher, wie funktionieren sie in der Gruppendynamik und kannst es dann so ein gewisser aufgreifen, ohne dass es jemals deine eigene Natur wird, aber du hast es zumindest verstanden. Und dafür kommt natürlich dann auch ein bisschen dieser analytische Blick, den der Komite braucht, um zu analysieren, ha ha, kennt ihr das, wenn jemand nicht in den Kreis der Gruppe reinkommt und dann... Wenn jemand die Gummibär in Beine singen kann, zum Beispiel. Die Gummibärchen, ja, aber sag ich mal, dieses studentische, du bist, ich sehe als bisschen diesen Archetyp-Studenten irgendwie, auch an deinem Stand-Up-Programm kommen Dinge irgendwie oft vor, so die Hausparty, dann Gras nehmen, wer besorgt Gras und mit Freunden unterwegs ist, halt irgendwie, One-Night-Stands, genau, One-Night-Stands, so dieses, ja, du nimmst die Frau mit nach Hause, dann ziehst du dir deine Kleidung an, so die Luke Mockridge-Klassiker. Bestellen Sie jetzt auf 72 CDs die Luke Mockridge-Klassiker. Of course. Gibt's das schon, die Klassiks? Bestellen Sie jetzt auf 72 CDs die Luke Mockridge-Klassiker. Genau, ja, du. Tram live präsentiert. Und du machst ja auch viel irgendwie an Unis und so und Hörsal, Comedy und so der ganze Kram. Also das ist ja schon so ein bisschen eine Comfortzone, diese soziale, studentische irgendwie, also ich mache hauptsächlich Tiergags auf Twitter, das ist meine Comfortzone. Ja, da gibt's auch eine Markttür. Ja, absolut. Erstaunlicherweise, 15.000 Follower, weiss ich nicht, viel so viel. Von den 9.000 gekauft sind, um das mal ganz ehrlich zu sein, die mir meine Mutter zum Geburtstag geschenkt hat. Weil sie sagte, ich hasse mal ein paar Freunde, mein Junge. So von wegen, es ist tatsächlich wahr. Was ich, also was meine Humorfabe ist, und das hat mir tatsächlich jemand mal gesagt, also ich glaube, ich habe das immer instinktiv gemacht, ich liebe es, ein Wir-Gefühl zu etablieren. Also auf der Bühne alle zu umarmen. Also ihr habt mich wahrscheinlich noch nie auf der Bühne gesehen. Nee, noch nie. Oder bei Nightwash, mal ja. Ach cool. Guck mal an. Wo ich moderiert habe oder wo ich auf der Bühne... Ja, hast du moderiert. Okay. Und ich versuche einfach immer, jeden zu umarmen. Also ich gründe auch spontan Bands, wenn ich auf Solotour bin und setze mich ganz klavier und singe mit allen irgendwelche Nineties-Hits und versuche irgendwie alle zu erreichen und das geht natürlich immer über diesen Wiedererkennungswert. Kennt ihr doch das, haben wir das zusammengelebt und am Ende ist so eine geile Stimmung, weil das so familiär ist und es gibt natürlich auch andere Comedians, die wie, wo Maxi Gestettenbauer auch einer ist zum Beispiel, den man so beobachten darf, wie durch so ein Schlüsselloch darf man so gucken, was der so macht. Und so gibt es verschiedene Humorfarben und meine ist einfach darauf, alle mitzunehmen auf eine tolle, bunte Reise. Es gibt natürlich auch Leute, die einem das dann vorwerfen, dass das eine Berechnung wäre und dass es natürlich einfacher ist, indem man so ein Wir-Gefühl ausstrahlt, alle ins Boot zu holen, wenn man halt die Gummibärchen bei einer mitsingt und alle lachen, dann kann man ja sagen, gut, es ist einfach, aber... Aber einer muss es ja machen, einer muss ja die Idee gehabt haben, ja.
Das ist korrekt, klar.
Und ich finde, ich liebe ja, und da seid ihr natürlich auch mit eurer Arbeit auch immer sehr,
ich versuche immer sehr am Zeitgeist zu sein.
Also gerade wenn ich Auftritte bei TV-Total habe, gucke ich mir die Sendung vorher an,
bin auf Twitter unterwegs und suche, was sind so gerade die Themen.
Ich habe dann spontan irgendwie letztes Mal bei TV-Total noch Hans Entertainment eingebaut,
einfach so in den Stand-Up eingebaut, weil die Nationalspieler zwanzig Minuten vorher den auf Facebook mit Amanako So True und da dachte ich, okay, der ist jetzt gerade im Thema drin, die Sendung wird abends ausgestrahlt, dann ziehe ich mir das auch noch an und spiele quasi diesen Zeitgeistball über den Schirm zurück. Aber als TV Total, wo du gerade da bist, bin ich unfassbar unangenehm als Comedian. Also wenn man jetzt nicht vielleicht ein Standing hat wie du, aber andere Leute, ich habe das Gefühl, da versagen so viele Leute. Weil die einfach rauskommen und wie ich eben sagte, die machen einfach nur ihren Text. Die kommen, also Stefan Raab ist der unvorbereitetste Mensch der Welt. Ja! Der kommt raus und sagt, ja, was haben wir jetzt, ja, jetzt kommt, jetzt, mal gucken. Und dann kommt ein Comedian, der fünf perfekt auswendig gelernte Minuten hat. Also das Gefälle ist so, das passt so gar nicht in den Rahmen der Sendung rein, wenn jemand so und deswegen versuche ich immer spontan Sachen einzubauen, das Publikum anzusprechen, Hans Entertainment noch einzubauen, also immer so, da sitzen ja auch nur junge Assis und die brauchen halt ihre Themen, deswegen wenn ich da bin, ficken wir vor zu Feuerstein und feuerfrei und los. Und alle rasten aus. Und alle rasten aus. Ja, aber das kann man natürlich auch irgendwo kritisch sehen. Es ist ja irgendwie dann, wie gesagt, recht einfach so. Es ist ja oft der einfache Weg, wenn man mit jemandem connecten will, irgendwie auf Dinge sich zu beziehen, die er auf jeden Fall kennt. Man sagt ja so, remembering is the lowest form of conversation, so ein bisschen, da macht man auf jeden Fall Punkte. Der denkt sich das immer aus, das ist das, das hat auch nie jemand vor ihm gesagt. In Sopranos kommt das Wort nochmal. Aber es ist so ein bisschen wie auf einer Party Wonderwall spielen. Mach ich übrigens im Soloprogramm. Ja, wirklich. Aber da muss ganz kurz. Herzlich willkommen im Spiel ausgedacht oder in Luke McCritney Soloprogramm. Aber da sieht man so ein bisschen das Gefälle, weil du bist dann, wenn du Wonderwall auf der Party spielst, der coole Typ, der überall ankommt und wir sind die Nerds in der Ecke, die keine Frau abkriegen und dann ist natürlich auch aus dem Punkt so ein bisschen so, ja, ist das einfach. Der Wichser, der halt einfach und wir haben die ganz feinen, säuberlichen Meta-Ironie-Humor-Gags, die wirklich nur die oberen zehn Prozent verstehen und auf die wir uns dann später einen runterholen oder eben nicht. Aber kannst du das irgendwie nachvollziehen, diese Kritik, dass man irgendwie so ein bisschen sagt, irgendwie populistisch irgendwie, spielt auf den kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner an irgendwie so, oder ist es für dich egal? Immer wenn du das selber gerne machst und das auch stehst. Also wenn mir das vorgeworfen, also tatsächlich wurde mir das mal vorgeworfen, ich hatte mal, bevor Luke die Woche und ich anfing, hatte ich einen Redakteur von der Zeit, der gerne ein Porträt mit mir machen wollte. Er wollte ein Porträt über mich machen. Ja, die Zeit, Hammer, machen wir auf jeden Fall. Ein Porträt malen. Und wir haben uns zwei Stunden getroffen, wir haben gequatscht und er fing ja schon, das war auch schon so ein Nerd, ne? Ja, das sind die typischen Zeittypen, die wollen ja die Mädchen, die wollen nicht dann durchschauen. Die typischen Zeittypen, Sorry, kann ich hier ganz so weiter in deinem Blatt mal ganz kurz scrollen. Wie Stefan Titze, neunzehn Jahre alt, Azubi bei der BTF gerade gesagt hat, ja das sind wieder die typischen Zeit-Typen. Du hast doch in deinem Leben noch nie Zeit-Typen. Wir lungern manchmal Zeit-Typen, wir lungern manchmal wie so eine gewisse Menschenart rum und man fragt sich, es ist Zeit oder was auch immer und es ist meistens Zeit. Ja, das ist Zeitcheidung-Magazin. Du hast keine Ahnung vom Medienbusiness.
Ich wollte auch mal vor, ich war gerade in einer Story, genau.
Und er war Zeitredakteur, es war aber für RP Online, also es war für die Rheinische Post.
Und der kam und wir haben uns total nett unterhalten und dann fing er schon zu sagen so, ja und du wichst also viele Comedians fangen ja an über ihre Schwächen und du bist so ein Typ, der hat keine Schwächen und früher in der Schule hätte ich dich nicht gemocht und worüber erzählst du denn und warum erzählst du nicht über die grossen Themen, Serdar so Mundschuh, der traut sich was und du nicht, wenn du sagst, ich bin 26 Jahre alt, ich bin gerade aus dem Studium fertig, mein Leben besteht aus Party, Saufen und tatsächlich diesen Spagat von der Kindheit ins Erwachsenwerden jetzt irgendwie damit klar zu kommen. Ich würde mich total verheben, wenn ich jetzt mit den grossen Themen anfangen würde,
deswegen würde ich sagen, ich bediene nicht den kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner, sondern ich bin einfach nur authentisch. Also ich rede darüber, was mir wichtig ist und versuche nur das wiederzugeben, was mich wirklich tangiert. Und dann kam ein Riesenartikel kurz vor Veröffentlichung, Luke Mockridge, muss der überhaupt sein? Aber es sind gute Fragen es sind gute Fragen, Kritik. Sollte sich jeder auch selbstverständlich machen? Muss das überhaupt sein? Es hilft einem auch total, dann abzuliefern, dann rauszugehen auf die Bühne und abzuliefern. Es hilft einem total dann sowas. Und ich fand das tatsächlich, und ich habe noch seine fucking Bionade bezahlt im Café Elefant im Agnesviertel. Es passt so gut ins Bild des Zeitjournalists, einfach da so eine Bionade drin. Ja, jetzt aber ganz kurz, du weißt jetzt wie ein Zeitsjournalist.
Ja klar, ich kann ihn euch gleich auf Facebook zeigen.
Hey, Cybermobbing!
Sebastian Dalkowski heißt der, könnt ihr gerne mal Facebooken.
Okay, der ist aber auf der Liste, aber ganz oben.
Ja, aber ich meine, mich einladen oder ein Porträt machen.
Ja gut, aber der Mann ist Journalist, das ist seine Aufgabe, der muss auch mal Kritik üben.
Ja, aber Porträt ist ja immer positiv.
Wenn ich aus meiner wertvollen freien Zeit sage, komm, ich treffe mich mit dir, lass uns was essen gehen und ich rede darüber und mir dann so eins reinzauen und dann postet er noch auf Facebook nach der ersten Sendung, wer für die dritte Aufzeichnung Karten hat, sollte sich lieber was anderes vornehmen, denn die wird eh bald abgesetzt. Und dann hab ich gesagt, ey, Alter. Und ja, hab dann tatsächlich diesen Typen gefacebookt und hab seinen Namen und hab den an sämtliche Managementfirmen im Comedy-Bereich und im Entertainment-Moderationsbereich weitergeleitet und habe gesagt, so, wenn der ein Porträt machen möchte, Obacht, der haut euch in die Pfanne. Okay, ja krass. Aber was mir aufgefallen ist an dir ist, dass du, und damit stichst du so ein bisschen raus irgendwie, ist, dass du nicht ironisch bist. Also ich finde, man hat ja gerade so bei den Entertainment-Deutschern irgendwie Jan Böhrmann, irgendwie Klaas, irgendwie so Halligalli, das ist alles, also die Leuchtfeuer, ist alles so sehr ironisch, also Metaebene, ironisch, ironisch und bei dir halt überhaupt nicht.
Also du hast zum Beispiel bei Lukes Woche hast du die Lukebox, wo du einfach ein Lied performst und nicht immer ganz schnell umziehst und verschiedene Lieder vorst.
Wo ich jetzt davor saß und erst mal dachte so, okay, was soll das? Was ist da der zweite Gedanke, der Schritt dahinter, der Text wurde nicht geändert, der Perform ist einfach nur, aber das ist also so ein Ding, was mir dann direkt auffallt, ah okay, er ist nicht ironisch, er macht es einfach, er macht es einfach, so ohne da irgendwie ironisch zu sein, das glaube ich sticht so ein bisschen raus, dass du da irgendwie was Besonderes bist, weil du nicht ironisch bist, ist das bewusst so oder kannst du es nicht oder willst du es nicht oder wie? Ja, also tatsächlich mache ich viel ins Ding, also ich gehe nicht mit Kalkül irgendwie an eine Sache ran. Ich bemerke natürlich auch, dass Leute wie Jan Böhmann, Klaas und Joko sehr ironisch und ich würde fast sogar sagen zynisch sind, was vom Feuilleton geliebt wird, aber die grosse Masse, und da werden wir wieder beim kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner, kann das glaube ich gar nicht genau abstrahieren. Also ich habe meinen Vater mal gefragt, ob er mal Bömermann oder Klaas gesehen hat, und Klaas und Joko, der Joko macht ja auch mit, und der sagt ja, aber das überfordert ihn. Also er sagt, mein Vater ist auch eine Entertainment-Instanz in Deutschland, viele Comedians hervorgebracht, aber das läuft auf so vielen Ebenen ab und du weißt gar nicht, ist das jetzt ein Insider-Gag von vorher und da musst du aber drei Wochen vorher und da musst du aber das Buch gelesen haben, um mit dem Film vergleichen zu können, um diese Pointe zu verstehen. Also ich glaube, das überfordert den Deutschen tatsächlich, wer mein Soloprogramm guckt. Also ich spiele, wenn ich ein Lucky-am-Look spiele, zweieinhalb Stunden und da ist auch viel Ironie und auch eine zweite Ebene und auch mal Gags mit einer Metaebene dabei. Aber ich glaube, ich habe einfach Spaß an dem, was ich mache. Denk da nicht grossartig drüber nach. Also es ist sehr Instinkt und wenig Kalkül. Und da sind wir ja bei Masse. Ich habe ja gelesen, dein Soloprogramm jetzt im Februar in der Lancess Arena. Also Riesending so. Das ist ja schon krass. Also wo willst du hin? Mario Barth, Stadion füllen? Ist das so dein Ding? Also, weißt du, wir sind auch so ein bisschen in der Zwickmühle, weil wir halt irgendwie mit diesem Ganzen an die Masse appellieren und so. Da kommen halt bei uns irgendwie so Mario Barth irgendwie und so diese ganzen, die wir jetzt nicht so ganz cool finden so. Man aber auch nicht weiss, warum. Also ich denke mir auch ganz oft, die deutsche Kommunistin ist vielleicht nicht so geil, wie man sich das vorstellt. Man guckt oft so nach Amerika, denkt sich so. Louis C.K. Klar, jeder Mann, vor allem jeder, der sich mit Comedy hier beschäftigt und jetzt auch von dir kommen halt Louis Lucy Kay und diese ganzen grossen Namen, aber man fragt sich ja irgendwie warum, also was ist gross anders?
Aber kennt ihr den Cook beispielsweise? Den finde ich zum Beispiel sensationell. Das ist auch jemand, an dem ich so ein bisschen meine Karriere auch anmodelliere, weil das auch so ein bisschen so eine Art Comedy-Popstar ist. Ja. Und ich war, muss ich ehrlich sagen, sehr überrascht, dass ihr mich angefragt habt, weil ich immer fest davon überzeugt bin, dass gerade die zynischen Metaebenen Comedians mich angucken und das wahrscheinlich komplett scheisse finden, was ich mache. Aber gerade deswegen leiden wir nicht ein. Ich habe dir ja auch geschrieben, ich habe gesagt, ist das ein Plot, ist das ein Prank? Also bei Jan Böbermann weiss man ja nie. Was wir sehr lustig fanden, wir fanden sehr lustig, entweder der schlechteste Prank der Welt, entweder das oder das ist kein Prank, wir wissen es nicht. Wir haben ihn gar nicht aufgenommen, haaa! Machen wir zufällig einen Prank, wir wissen es nicht. Wir fanden es auch so, du hast ja geschrieben, dass du glaubst, dass ein Jan Bömermann dich nicht mag und du es schade findest, hast du auch mal gesagt. Das habe ich euch gesagt oder? Ja, ich glaube schon. Habe ich das in einem Video gesagt oder? War das in einem Video? Ich glaube, in einem Video war. Irgendwo hast du es glaube ich gesagt, was ganz interessant ist, also wir haben uns gefragt, woher das kommt. Ja, aber genau aus dem Grund, dass Jan Bömermann ein verkapptes intellektuelles Genie zu scheinen ist, um den Satz grammatikalisch falsch zu Ende zu bringen. Aber dann auf Leute wie mich guckt und sagt, ja, das ist doch eh nur so ein Justin Bieber. Ich habe auch mal die, kennt ihr die Anstalt, was ich sensationell finde. Also das ist ja wirklich mit dem Filetmesser der Satire geht es da komplett durch alle Medien und zeitgeistrelevanten Themen. Und ich würde da so gerne hin und mein Kumpel Abdel Karim und Kirbekus, die sind alle immer da. Und ich habe auch mal gesagt, ich würde da gerne hin, aber die werden mich nie einladen, weil ich für die wahrscheinlich nur in dieser Justin Bieber Comedy SchSchublade drin bin mit Cappy, Schief und ...
Man hat das Gefühl, dass die Anstalt zum Beispiel ist sehr moralisch und so, das gefällt mir immer nicht so daran.
Es ist so, glaube ich, sehr deutsch. Es ist so dieses aus der Not heraus ...
Kabarett-hafter, ja.
Ja, es ist Kabarett-hafter, dieses aus der Not, aus dem politischen heraus so ein Comedy zu entwickeln, wo ich immer das Gefühl habe, die Amerikaner, die nehmen das alles ein bisschen lockerer, für die es einfach Stand-Up ist eine fucking Kunstform.
Die machen halt ihr Ding und denen ist egal, erstmal ist es egal. In Amerika ist Stand-Up sehr, also da gibt es keine Lichtshow, da gibt es kein Intro, da gibt es kein... Sehr puristisch, sehr künstlerisch. Sehr puristisch, kleine Bühne, alkoholisiertes Publikum, auch nur eine Stunde am Stück, keine Pause, damit die Gastro nichts verdient. Also ich bin da mehr entertainig. Also ich würde mich auch wahrscheinlich gar nicht als Stand-Up-Comedian sehen, weil Stand-Up-Comedian sind für mich moderne Philosophen, die irgendwie die Realität auf lustige Art und Weise abbilden. Und ich sehe mich, glaube ich, mehr als einfach Entertainer, der sich ans Klavier setzt, der eine Gitarre rausholt, der schlagfertig im Interview ist, der dann auch mal eine Stand-up-Comedy-Nummer schreiben kann, der moderieren kann. Also ich lieber so ein bisschen auf allen Hochzeiten tanzen.
Aber gibst dann dafür die Anstalt auf, sozusagen?
Tatsächlich, ja, verkaufe meine Seele am Sat.1 und kann dafür nie wieder für 300 Euro bei der Anstalt aufsachen. Aber war sie denn was wert?
Die Seele?
Ja.
Das wird sich, das erscheint die Zeit. Du bist mit Lamborghini angekommen vom Studio, muss man sagen. Ja, mit meinem Lamborghini Auris. Das ist eigentlich krass. Naja, nee, aber stört dich das wirklich, dass du da nicht ankommst? Weil ich meine, du scheinst ja auch viel dafür zu tun, dass du da nicht ankommst. Also wenn ich mir überlege, du würdest da gerne mitspielen, irgendwie wärst du gerne dabei. Das ist ein gutes Wort, ich würde gerne mitspielen in den Häuferumlauf, Klaas, Jan, Kebekus, Hanstall. Hast aber nicht so viel Bock, da viel dafür zu tun. Oder auf die KitKat-Werbung zu erzählen. Du hast ja gesagt, du machst selber das gerne, was du machst. Aber das verstehe ich nicht, warum willst du einerseits da mitmachen, machst du aber auf der anderen Seite KitKat-Werbung. Das ist ja offensichtlich ein Widerspruch. Wir können es gerne mal testen, wofür du Werbung machst. Wir haben sehr viel KitKat gekauft. Ja, wir haben nur KitKat gekauft, damit du keine Probleme kriegst mit Werbung oder was. Damit ich wohlfühle. Und es gibt einen, man muss die richtig aufmachen, ne? Oh, du wirst ja der KitKat-Werbung. Also man reisst ihn hier auf, zieht es an der oberen Ecke und reisst dann entlang, ach geil, bricht den Ersten ab, nimmt den Ersten mit der rechten Hand raus und bricht sie dann in der Mitte und tut den rechten zuerst in den Mund. Das musste ich in der Werbung. Er bricht den Riegel nochmal in der Mitte und ist dann von der Mitte aus nach oben. Mit der rechten. Ich habe jetzt ein kleines Loch in der Ecke, ich habe ein KitKat. Ja Gott, Werbung ist natürlich so ein Ding, wo man sagt, macht man, macht man, also ich, macht ja jeder Werbung,
natürlich, dass Nestle Wasserreservoire in der dritten Welt aufkauft und jetzt überall zugeballert wird, das war mir so auch nicht bewusst, ich habe meiner Agentur gesagt, check das mal, ist Nestle ein Verein, wo man, ich glaube, wer sucht, der findet, Also, ich rufe mal an. Nein.
Die haben mir gesprochen, die haben mir gesagt, nee, was ist er? No, no, no.
Nein, Quatsch, nein, nein.
Äh, die haben gesagt, nee, was ist. No, no, no. Nein, Quatsch, nein, nein. Äh, klar, also ich dachte, KitKat war für mich auch nicht Nessler, also das, dass die, und ich sage jetzt auch nicht, Nessler ist der Teufel. Steht sehr dick drauf, was mir auch noch nicht aufgefallen ist, was mir auch noch nicht aufgefallen ist. Aber da entscheidet man sich zusammen mit der Agentur und mit seinem Management und mit seinen Leuten, so können wir das machen, ja, kann man machen. Und dann war das für mich eine positive, gute Marke. Und wer entscheidet da mehr, das Management oder du? Ich kann sagen, Daumen hoch, Daumen runter. Also die sagen hier, dass das Angebot liegt, da hast du Bock drauf. Und die sagen, ja Gott, drei Videos auf YouTube mit Joyce zusammen. Also das wirkte auch sehr bei mir und ich finde, das hat Spaß gemacht und war völlig, völlig okay. Joko und Klaas machen auch Werbung für die Limonade, Stefan Raab hat Werbung für Ueltier gemacht, also ich glaube, Atze Schröder für den Brutzler, also mit dem fantastischen Slogan Atze holt die Wurst raus. Ja, aber das soll die Frage sind, dass so die Vorbilder, ne? Also wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie Ja, aber das soll die Frage sind, dass so die Vorbilder, ne, also wie, wie, wie, wir können das nicht ganz einordnen, also wo bist, bist du dann schon so Vorbild, Atze, Schroeder, Mario Barth oder sagst du da, ja, das ist nicht, also wo willst du hin, so wer willst du mal sein in zehn Jahren? Und das ist die wirklich grosse Frage, elementar wichtige Frage, die, mit der ich mich gerade befasse, sowohl als Comedian, aber auch als Mensch. Also ich habe das Gefühl, dass durch wie meine Karriere gelaufen ist, ich bin mit 22, habe ich die Uni abgeschlossen, war fertig, oder mit 23 und habe dann angefangen, sofort Comedy zu machen und habe nie dieses Jahr im Ausland gehabt, wo man einfach mal mit dem Rucksack durch Laos tourt und Fotos von Facebook macht..000 Euro lässt, einfach weil man es nicht hat. Genau, also die Eltern lassen 30.000 Euro da. Und einen Surfkurs gemacht. Also ich glaube meine menschliche Entwicklung hat tatsächlich, ist noch gar nicht so weit wie die meiner Professionalität. Also ich muss für mich wirklich noch mal neu eruieren, wo will ich hin, wer will ich überhaupt sein, was für ein Mensch will ich sein. Nimm dir doch mal so ein Ja. Nimm dir mal so ein Ja. Nimm dir mal ein Ja, einfach mal die Seele bauen lassen, Surfkurs. Ich sag mal so, wir würden deinen Sendeplatz nehmen, also das ist klar, dafür ist gesorgt. Und ich glaube, Maxi Stettenbauer auch. Ich habe nämlich am Anfang, am Ende glaube ich, als wir nach dem Interview haben wir die Frage gestellt, da haben wir über ProSieben gesprochen, das war der Tag, glaube ich, wo irgendwie die Bild-Zeitung geschrieben hat, dass du der Stefan-Rath-Nachfolger wirst. Und dann habe ich mich so auf angesprochen und er meinte, nein, nein, das ist nicht so. Irgendwie so, als wüsste er das oder wollte er das gar nicht, weil das ist sehr lustig. Gar nicht wahrhaben wollen. Nein, nein, es ist er nicht. Auf gar keinen Fall, ich weiss das, hier ist das Ding. Die Dinge fragen mich immer, was ist eigentlich los? Das ist meine Maxi-Parodik. Muss man Maxi Schattenbauer mittlerweile im Imitationskanon haben? Ich hoffe, dass er grösser wird, dass er endlich damit Geld verdienen kann. Das geht mir auch immer so. Mir geht es bei Oli P so, der einzige, den ich nachmachen kann, aber der wird auch nicht mehr. Der einzige, den ich nachmachen kann, bin ich selber. Und ich hoffe, dass ich deshalb... Obwohl du hast viel von Jan Böbermann, das ist mir bei dem letzten Podcast... Meinst du rein optisch? Nee, von der Rhetorik, von dem Sprachduktus... Ich glaube, das ist nur das ist nur weil ich sehr schnell spreche, wenn man die Hälfte der Börder ... Du machst ihm gerade ein sehr grosses Lob. Ich glaube, er fühlt sich gerade sehr. Ist sehr nett, dankeschön. Ist es nett, ja. Aber zu welchen Entschlüssen bist du denn gekommen, in diesem Nachdenken, wo ich hin will? Das ist, dass ich das nicht weiss, dass ich aber glaube ich genau wie jeder, wie viele 26-Jährige, die in dieser Generation Y oder Generation X, ich weiss gar, welche Generation wir gerade sind. Das ist auch so ein Ding, wir wissen nicht, ich glaube, wir sind ein bisschen, nee, wir sind die Generation, die Generation Scharfes S. Ja, Generation Raute oder was auch immer noch. Generation Emoticon, ja. Sonderzeichen. Ja, wir sind diese Generation, ja, ich kann ein Praktikum machen, ich kann Arzt werden, ich kann aber auch ein Startup gründen und welcher der werden. Ich muss aber, ich muss aber ein Praktikum machen, so. Also, keiner weiß irgendwie von, alles kann, nichts muss. Ja, aber ich meine, du hast jetzt schon wahnsinnig viele Türen offen. Also ich meine, du bist ja jetzt schon in einer sehr... Ja, aber das ist doch das Problem. Du könntest wahrscheinlich jetzt erstmal acht Jahre gar nichts machen, wäre es finanziell jetzt nicht so dabei. Du kannst Bücher schreiben, du kannst Triebücher schreiben, du kannst Hörspiele machen, du kannst... Du bist mit KitKat versorgt. Nicht mit KitKat. Also du hast ja wirklich alles offen. Ich verbringe Zeit mit Stefan Raab und quatsche mit dem und sehe den so, wie der so ist. Und der ist ein sehr in sich gekehrter, reflektierter, schillerer. Also du willst einen Duschkopf machen? Bade, aber ohne. Du willst einen Duschkopf machen. Ich sehe schon. Nee, aber ich verbringe Zeit mit dem und sage, boah, das ist echt ein faszinierender Typ, ich möchte so sein wie der, der ist cool. und dann verbringe ich Zeit mit Olli Pocher, der ein fantastischer Typ ist.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, ich will auf gar keinen Fall so werden wie der, ganz im Gegenteil, wo ich sage, boah, ich möchte genau so sein wie der, der ist cool, der fährt einfach vor das Fußballstadion und sagt, hier ist Olli Pocher, lass mich mal rein und dann gehen wir zusammen rein und gucken uns das Fußballspiel an, wo ich genau so sage, boah, wie geil ist das denn? Also ich bin selber so voller Optionen und Türen und weiss eigentlich gar nicht, wer
Luki eigentlich sein will und rede da auch viel mit meinen Eltern drüber, die natürlich
auch in dem Business sind. Oder eine enorme Expertise bekommen kannst. Ja, aber ich wollte gerade sagen, ist nicht das vielleicht auch gleichzeitig Segen und Fluch, dass du gerade schon in dieser Entertainment-Familie aufgewachsen bist und da halt schon sehr schnell irgendwo formatiert bist, dass du dann halt vielleicht in so einer Entertainment-Maschine steckst, die dir vielleicht manchmal irgendwie schon zu weit vorausfährt und du sagst so, ey, sitze ich überhaupt am Steuer so?
Entertainment-Maschine ist das nicht. Wir sind halt so eine Kleinkunstfamilie, meine Eltern haben beide ein Theater gegründet, also ich bin mit dieser Theaterwelt groß geworden und das ist absolut in meiner DNA drin, ich mache genau das, wofür ich quasi gebaut bin, also ich glaube schon, wenn ich auf der Bühne stehe, und das ist vielleicht die Krux an der Sache, ich fühle mich wirklich nur hundertprozentig wohl, wenn ich auf der Bühne stehe. Wenn da tausend Leute sitzen und ich habe das Mikro in der Hand und da fühle ich mich super selbstbewusst, da fühle ich mich gut, da fühle ich mich schön, also ich will da nicht runter. Oh, das Shirt. F schon weiter, Shirt werden wir nicht frei. Aber auf einer Party beispielsweise, auf einer Party fühl ich mich völlig weh. Deswegen schieße ich mich ab und ertrage nicht diese ... Ich muss auch ganz ehrlich sagen, als ich da bei Nightwatch war, ich hatte davor schon so ein paar Stand-ups von dir gesehen, fand ich es schon immer nicht so komplett überragend. Dann hab ich mir, okay,, gucke ich mir mal an, aber ich muss sagen, gerade deine Moderation hat mich echt umgehauen, also da muss ich echt sagen, wie du spontan warst, auf die Dinge reagiert hast, irgendwie, man merkt, du machst es auch schon ewig und das ist halt genau so da in dieser enge, schwitzende Raum, wo halt irgendwie ständig Dinge, durch die irgendwie Sachen schmeißt man sich zu und dann passiert was und dann geht jemand an der Fensterscheibe vorbei, so, dass es genau deine Welt ist, wo du auf alles eingehen kannst und so und da dachte ich mir schon, wow, wow, Respekt, also mit welcher Geschwindigkeit und Präzision er da auf die Sachen eingeht. Das war schon echt das, wo ich mir dachte, schade, dass man das im Fernsehen gar nicht so oft sieht von dir, weil da ja oft irgendwie dann viel auch in einer Show irgendwie einfach vorbereitet ist und halt dann irgendwie Texte abgelesen werden und dieses krass spontane so einfach mal Freestylen gar nicht so vorkommt. Was ja auch auch im Fernsehen generell selten vorkommt, muss man sagen.
Was sagen die Leute nach jeder Aufzeichnung? Das Beste war das Warm-up.
Ja, ja, ja, oder diese Online-Exclusive-Sachen. Ja, ich glaube Fernsehen ist, ich liebe Fernsehen, ich mache gerne Fernsehen, aber mein Element ist tatsächlich jetzt gerade in diesem Moment die Bühne und KitKat Werbespot. Also die Bühne ist das, Tourleben, Bühne zum Publikum, Dialog, da fühle ich mich einfach pudelwohl, da bin ich am meisten bei mir. Und ich glaube, ich muss für mich einfach erwachsen werden und herausfinden, was ich will. Ich sehe Künstler wie Jan Böhmermann oder Joko und Klaas und da sieht man so ein Wertesystem, auch wenn die sich irgendwie Donuts in die Stirn spritzen und sich die Eier... Ich bin so geil, dass er nur noch darauf reduziert wird. Ja, ja, das ist auch der größte, wenn er das will. Ja, ja, das ist nur noch der Donut in der Stirn. Ja, ja, ja. Aber du merkst, die haben ein Wertesystem und die... Aber will er, glaube ich, auch nicht mehr sein. Also hast du nicht das Gefühl, dass, ich glaube, zumindest das Klaas, glaube ich, ein bisschen mehr will, als das, wo er gerade ist? Auch mit seiner Musikkarriere, jetzt Gloria irgendwie groß so... Ja, der will auch was anderes. Ich glaube, das ist auch so einer, der auch vielleicht gerade an so einem Punkt ist wie du, dass er nicht genau weiß, was will der kleine Klasi eigentlich. Ja, oder er sagt halt, ich habe jetzt so ein Standing, dass es scheissegal ist, was ich mache, weil ich habe genug Geld, ich habe genug Türen offen, ich kann jetzt auch einfach mal sagen, ich tue durch die Deutschland und die Leute kommen zu meinen Auftritten. Ich glaube aber nicht, dass er will, dass beim Bundesvision Song Contest die Halligalli-Fans für Gloria anrufen. Ich glaube, ich will der nicht. Nee, glaube ich auch nicht, aber ich glaube, deswegen konstruiert er Gloria vielleicht auch so ein bisschen an Halligalli vorbei, einfach mal, um anders zu werden. Ja genau, um anders wahrgenommen zu werden. Ja genau, um anders wahrgenommen zu werden. Könntest du dir das auch mal vorstellen, so einen ganz anderen Weg eingehen, irgendwie so lesbisches Puppentheater oder so, russische Malerei oder so? Das ist aber vorbereitet, das ist dir jetzt nicht gerade in diesem Moment als Beispiel ein Gagdokument. Ja, da haben wir das. Ich muss ein bisschen runter scrollen. Und das Shirt war da oben. Nein, das waren die einzigen beiden Sachen, die da standen. Hat die Notizen für mich gemacht? Wir haben Fragen total cool. Die unvorbereiteten Gangs merkt man daran, dass sie keinen Sinn ergeben. Jetzt ist das Wummeerde. Nee, aber könntest du dir das auch mal vorstellen, was ganz anderes zu machen, so ein Film-Noir zu drehen? Ich habe ein Film-Noir zu drehen. Nee, ich liebe tatsächlich Kino und Film, aber auch Schweighöfer und Schweiger und so. Also ich finde, das deutsche Kino ist Lichtjahre hinter Amerika sowieso. Ich habe jetzt mal kurz davor, so welche Richtung schlägt das ein. Das hätte auch nicht ganz eine Richtung. Nee, aber bei dir weiss man es nicht. Ich bin ja nicht ironisch. Selbst französisches Cinema oder selbst in Belgien gibt es wieder geile Filme oder so. Da sind wir echt noch hinterher. Ich finde, fuck you, Goethe, ich habe es nicht gesehen, aber ich kann mir in der Infobacht vorstellen, warum das funktioniert. Kartoffelsalat. Da irgendwie so süße Kartoffelsalat. Hast du ihn gesehen? Nein. Wir haben ihn beide gesehen im Kino. Ja, wie man erwartet. Katastrophe, ja. Katastrophe. Auf einmal hat man eine neue Ebene erreicht, wo wir auch schon drüber gesprochen haben. Aber ich finde das gut, dass YouTuber ein bisschen ihre Sterblichkeit erfahren. Voll gut. Die laufen mit einem absoluten Super-Held-Superman-Schild. Laufen die gegen die Wand, gegen die Realitätswand? Wir hatten auch einmal bei Nightwarsh, der bei uns aufgetreten ist. Echt? Welcher war das? Das sage ich nicht, aber einer der Grössten. Ach krass. Einer der Grössten und der ist aufgetreten und ist komplett, also komplett abgekackt. Wir laden die immer hoch und das wurde dann noch boykettiert, dass es nicht hochgeladen wird. Und es ist gut, dass sie auch mal merken, ey, man muss auch was können. Es reicht nicht einfach zu sagen, ey cool, das ist meine Heizung und das ist mein Stuhl und wir gehen jetzt mal in den Zoo. Aber in der Welt bist du ja auch so ein bisschen drin. Du hast ja auch ein YouTube-Channel-Projekt geschadet, ich weiss nicht, ob das aktiv noch läuft und so.
Snooze, ja doch habe ich mit ...
Das kann so ganz kurz dein Mikrofon ein bisschen näher an ich.
Oh, so will ich es werden.
Ihr hört ja gar nicht mit.
Ich bin ja immer ein bisschen nervös.
Jetzt laufen wir jetzt.
Aber jetzt passen wir.
Jetzt kann es die ganze Zeit sehr weit weg, nicht dass ich.
Ja, ja, nee, ist schon okay, aber nur das ist ...
Wir haben ja einen Ausschlag, ist es sehr gut.
Alles in Ordnung.
Alles so gut.
Ja, wir kamen ja von Pong, also ich wurde, ich war auf einer Comedy-Mix-Show und da war das Team von Pong und das war eine, für die, die es nicht kennen, das war ein YouTube-Channel kreiert von Mediakraft, die, ja, Mediakraft sind so ein bisschen die lesbischen Puppenspieler von YouTube, die von oben quasi die Marionetten und die Stücke... Lief auch nicht so gut, also war so konstruiert als der neue heiße Shit und ging... Schoss nach oben und dann schoss es genauso wieder nach unten. Aber sag mir was und ich kenne mich null aus dem YouTube. Ich habe schon mal von Pong gehört. Das war der ... Pong meinst du vielleicht. Wie verwechselst du das? Und da habe ich Joyce und Jules kennengelernt und wir haben uns echt super verstanden. Und Joyce ist wirklich eine fantastische, super coole Sau einfach, die ich gerne mag, mit der ich gerne arbeite. Und wir arbeiten auch gut zusammen. Also wir sind in Sketchen zusammen und und merken so, wir spielen gut voneinander, deswegen habe ich sie auch bei Luke die Woche und ich noch reingeholt und haben jetzt diesen YouTube-Channel noch und das ist einfach für mich ein geiler Multiplikator, weil man sagt, die Kids gucken kein Fernsehen, also mein Bruder ist 18 und der sagt 20, 15, leck mich am Arsch, ich gucke, wann ich will. Also ich bin eigentlich kalkuliert dahingegangen, wo die Fans sind, weil ich ein Mainstream-Schwimmender Wichser bin. Aber du machst das auch schon, weil du da machen kannst, was du willst, oder? Auch, ja. So ein Ventil. Das ist aber bei uns auch so ein Ventil. Macht Spaß, kannst machen, was du willst, es gibt keinen Sender, der sagt hier das, das und das. Und ja, es ist eine coole Sache. Und Brainpool macht das auch. Und wenn ich eine Idee habe, sage ich, ich würde gerne das und das drehen, dann haben die direkt Kameraleute da und wir drehen das und das macht Spaß. Aber ist das auch so ein bisschen deine Zielgruppe so, also ich habe das Gefühl, deine Zielgruppe ist jünger als du. Ist das so? Ja, die sind so, geht so ab, ich habe das ganze mit meinem Kaugummi rumgespielt und dann wieder reingesteckt, habe ich gemerkt. Das ist cool, wir sind ecklich, ne? Ganz geil eigentlich. Ich frage mich jetzt so, wie du es geschafft hast, das KitKat am Kaugummi vorbeizuessen. Aber auch... Ich habe das KitKat nicht gegessen.
Ach so.
Auch Klage incoming.
Uiuiui, da schneiden wir raus und lupen es einfach durchgehend.
Das KitKat nicht gegessen.
Wir schneiden auch aus allen Sätzen, die du gesagt hast, ich hasse KitKat oder so.
Ihr habt einen Klebe verstanden.
Das war gerade diese ersten 20 Minuten, wo ich hier auch randaliert habe und die KitKats rumgeschmissen habe. Das war echtisch, ne? Bitte, stell das bitte alles raus. Aber warum hast du den Tonmann nochmal so angegangen? Was war denn da los? You have a break, Luke, have a break. Da bin ich halt ein bisschen sensibel drauf. Du hast mir immer so ein bisschen deine fünf Minuten, ne? Das habe ich schon das Gefühl. All Great Divas, ne? Kennst du eine, kennst du alle. Was war mit der Frage? Ich weiß es gar nicht. Ich weiß es auch nicht mehr. Keine Ahnung, ich will was anderes reden. Ob ich in euren Podcast mal gehört habe, das war die Frage. Genau, also Frage zwei. Der Recall, das ist übrigens Comedyhandbuch Nummer eins, der Recall. Aber ganz kurz, das ist ja ein wichtiger Punkt, weil das ist ja, das ist mir schon oft aufgefallen, das ist ja auch der klassische Closer bei vielen Comedians. Worum gehst du jetzt hier komplett in Fragen verloren Verantwortung. Ganz kurz, der klassische Recall nennt man das.
Oder Reincorporation oder Callback.
Also ganz kurz, zum Beispiel Maxi Schettenbauer hat in seinem Programm den Teil, wo er sagt, er lässt sich Essen nur noch von Rewe liefern, er geht nicht mehr zu Rewe einkaufen, sondern lässt sich nur noch liefern.
So, dann geht es dann im Programm weiter, la la la la la la la und ganz am Schluss sagt er dann so, das ist etwa genau das gleiche.
Es sagt er dann so am Schluss, sagt er noch irgendwas und dann, ah, die Klingel, Rewe ist da.
So, ne, das ist auf der Bühne wesentlich lustiger, als ich es jetzt gesagt habe, weil der Zuschauer bis dahin natürlich das alles vergessen hat und dann nochmal, ah, okay, Rückkehr. Wo man auch sagen kann, das ist ja per se jetzt nicht, das ist ja kein Gag, ist ja nicht lustig, da ist ja jetzt kein kreativer neuer Gedanke da, sondern es ist einfach nur eine Erinnerung, der aber gut funktioniert. Das ist ein Prinzip des Running Gags eigentlich, dass man die Zuschauer belohnt, die drangeblieben sind. Das ist einfach nur ein Handwerk, es ist einfach ein handwerklicher Kniff. Menschen lieben es, auf der Innenseite eines Inside-Gags zu sein. Und wenn du einen Inside-Gag selber etablierst und das dann später nochmal abfeuerst, dann sagen alle, wir wissen Bescheid, wir waren eben schon hier. Aber Leute hassen das, wenn die nicht drin sind. Wenn Leute von Instagram ausgeschlossen werden, ist das furchtbar. Was auch so ein Partythema ist, wenn zwei Leute sich unterhalten über die letzte Party und du warst nicht dabei.
Finde ich interessant, es passt ja auch total gut zu deinem Ansatz zu sagen, ich will alle umarmen, ich will alle eine Gruppe holen und dann zu sagen, man nutzt diese Insider-Gags und man baut in diesen paar Minuten oder in der Stunde, was auch immer, je nach Grösse, halt irgendwie so eine kleine Insider-Gemeinde auf und grast das dann halt ab. Und die Frage ist also, jetzt um nochmal zurückzukommen, was man will auf der Bühne und ob der kleinste gemeinsame Nenntez so einfach ist, ich glaube, ich will einfach Leute unterhalten. Ich will, dass Leute lachen, ich will, dass Leute singen, dass sie Spaß haben, dass sie da rausgehen und sagen, boah, war das geil. Und ob das dem Feingeistigen zu platt ist oder dem Mysantropen irgendwie zu happy.
Moment, aber gibt es denn überhaupt keine Comedy, die du scheisse findest?
Also Mario Barth oder so, gibt es nicht irgendjemanden, wo du sagst, der ist...
Mario Barth ist für mich handwerklich genial.
Also der ist vom Handwerk, wie er das macht, das Thema ist...
Aber das ist ja nicht die Frage, es geht ja nicht um Handwerk.
Also gibt es nicht irgend...
Also ich meine, du kannst doch nicht alle mögen, es muss doch auch jemanden geben, wo
du sagst, der ist scheisse.
Also ich will dich jetzt nicht, wie ich das zu Kollegen verrät oder so, aber halt einfach nur so vom Stil, wo du sagst, das ist nicht so meins, das ist zu platt oder zu einfach oder irgendwas. Also ich finde die grossen Namen, jetzt ohne einen Namen zu nennen, die grossen Namen sind mir, die auf den grossen Sender sind. Mit dem grossen Namen im Hintergrund vor allem, mit dem grossen Namen dann stehen. Ja, das ist mir dann manchmal doch so ein bisschen zu einfach, ja, tatsächlich. Und ich mag es, wenn es ein bisschen mehr einen Twist hat. Und ich, also dass ihr jetzt sagt irgendwie, dass bei mir keine Meta-Ebene dabei ist oder dass keine Ironie dabei ist, also ich würde euch sehr gerne mal einladen zu meinem Soloprogramm. Ja, gerne. Und ist in einem kleinen Stadttheater in Deutz, heißt Längsches Arena. Hashtag läuft sehr gut. Sag dir so ein Fur mit seinem Lamborghini, weg! Wo kann ich mein Heli parken? Nein, kommt vorbei und dann können wir gerne nachher nochmal resümieren, ob wir sagen, was gutes und da machen. Ja, wir machen dann ein Review, wir haben dann so eine Liste, wo wir genau jeden jeden nochmal auseinander nehmen. Weil ich habe wirklich auch den Angst, ich sitze mit meiner Redaktion zusammen und sage manchmal so, Mann, ich möchte eigentlich von den Micky Beisenherzes, Gernd Hürmermans, Joko und Claases und Kebekusses und Klaus von Wagner und von der Anstalt heute schon, von denen möchte ich eigentlich gut gefunden werden. Aber du sagst, ich tue halt nichts dafür. Nee, aber ich sehe es so, dass du nicht gleichzeitig die Masse haben kannst und das Vöhrtor aka Jan Böhrmann. Das geht in meinen Augen nicht. Und wenn du sagst, ich will die Masse, musst du für mich nach meiner Logik ganz klar sagen, ja, dann muss mir Jan Böhrmann scheissegal sein. Weil du kannst nicht beide haben. Ich glaube, doch. Oder glaubst du es doch? Doch, also Louis C.K. spielt grosse Hallen. Ja gut, aber das ist Amerika, weisst du, da hast du halt nochmal ein riesiges Rappen mit ganzen Leuten. Aber er hat auch noch mit zu kämpfen, das ist ja auch in seiner Serie so, dass er die ganze Zeit als der Comics-Comic bezeichnet wird, der dann nur für Comedians funktioniert. Dass er so ein Comedian ist, der halt nicht für die breite Masse funktioniert. Augenscheinlich ja doch, aber es ist vielleicht auch so ein gehyptter Typ.
Vielleicht ist das auch eine chronische Unzufriedenheit, die jeder Mensch in sich hat, dass man immer das haben will, was man nicht hat. Also ich glaube, dass vielleicht ein Jan Böhmermann gerne mehr Quote oder mehr Star-Appeal hätte, kann ich mir vorstellen. Aber was ist denn wichtiger, die Masse oder die Klasse? Dass ich mit mir glücklich bin und dass ich selber mit mir leben kann und damit happy bin, was ich mache. Mit vielen Sachen auf der Bühne bin ich total happy, habe ich ja gesagt. Wenn ich zwei Stunden alleine auf der Bühne bin, mega happy. Mit vielen anderen Projekten, die ich bisher gemacht habe, bin ich zufrieden, aber bin noch nicht so in meinem Element wie auf der Bühne. Also es gibt in meiner Fernsehsendung, wo du sagst, Lukebox und so, da waren viele Sachen dabei, wo ich gesagt habe, vieles Schönes, aber ich lerne da noch. Ich bin da absolut noch in den Kinderschuhen und kann auch jeden Hate nachvollziehen, wenn der unlustiger Spaß oder was auch immer sage. Ja, ist dann vielleicht in deinen Augen so. Aber der Journalist, der da schreibt, wird halt auch an jeden genannt, steht ganz oben auf deiner Liste. Absolut, der ist er, der macht auch nicht mehr lang. Ja, aber das ist eine interessante Frage, mit der man sich tatsächlich auseinandersetzen muss. Ist es Mainstream oder Indie? Ich finde Joko und Klaas mit dem Duell um die Welt, das habe ich auch dem zuständigen Realisator, der das gedreht hat, der mich am Flughafen mal gesehen hat und gesagt hat, ey, guck dir das heute an, das ist geil geworden, habe ich mir angeguckt und habe ihm noch geschrieben. Ich finde, dieser Spagat zwischen Indie-Musik und Pop-Album ist tatsächlich ziemlich geil. In der Musik gibt es ja, also ein guter Popsong funktioniert ja auch auf mehreren Ebenen. Also Bohemian Rhapsody ist absolut massenkompatibel, aber wird auch vom Foyotan gefeiert. Also ich glaube, so diesen Spagat kann man schon irgendwie hinkriegen. Das ist halt ein ein Jahrhundertsong, ne? Also da ist das schon, aber gut, klar, Ziele hoch. Auch, auch, auch. Ich habe jetzt kein Problem damit. Little Miss Sunshine, auch ein Film, wo ich sage, das ist fantastisch. Aber ist das Masse, Little Miss Sunshine? Doch mittlerweile schon. Der war, glaube ich, erfolgreich, ja. Aber ein paar Transformer, glaube ich, hätten nicht geschadet für Box Office. Ja, das wäre ein anderer Film geworden. Aber das ist auch so, was im Kino heutzutage läuft. Ich kann damit wirklich, also Avengers, weiss nicht, ob ihr da ... Nee, kein Foto raus. Ich kann da nichts mit ankommen. Avengers nicht, Fast and Furious nicht, Transformers nicht, Captain America und Iron Man. Das interessiert Hulk, interessiert mich überhaupt nicht. Also in einer Welt. Das ist so, Jurassic Park habe ich ja letztens gesehen, den neuen. Ja, da haben wir auch drüber gesprochen, weil ich ein riesen Jurassic Park Verein bin. Aber das interessiert mich nicht. Aber ich fand den einfach furchtbar. Die Figuren nehme ich nicht mit, die Handlung tangiert mich überhaupt nicht. Man hat das Gefühl, dass die sehr viel auf Optik Wert legen neuerdings und so sehr viel, es muss einfach viel gut aussehen, neue Technik muss ausgereist werden, aber es ist halt wenig auf Inhalt. Ja, das ist schade. Was schaust du dann gerne an? Also was sind so in den letzten Jahren Filme gewesen, wo du sagst, das ist Luke Mockridge's Seal of Approval? Filme, die du gesehen haben musst. Oh Boy, habt ihr den gesehen? Nein. Oh Boy, du hattest den schwarz-weiss. Sorry, jetzt werde ich angegangen.
Und das hat für mich absolut funktioniert. Ich mag so Sachen wie Garden State, einfach süße kleine Geschichten, die nicht so viel wollen. Little Miss Sunshine fand ich sensationell. Ich habe mir jetzt Birdman, ich war eben noch bei Saturn, ich habe meinen Rucksack hier. Wollt ihr sehen, was ich mir gerade bei Saturn vergab. Das ist ja sehr gut, mehr Product Placement, wooo! Das ist ja toll. Also ein Unboxing, ein Haul. Wir machen den Luke Mockridge Haul. Was hat er alles eingekauft? Luke Mockridge kauft einen. Drei Blu-rays noch verpackt. Hier sind vier KitKat rausgefallen. Okay, Ex Machina, Spinal Tap, wunderbar, und Place Beyond the Pines. Ja, kann man nichts sagen. Drei gute Filme. Dann hast drei gesehen? Ja, kann man nichts sagen. Spinal Tap ist ein absoluter Klassiker, der ist ein bisschen der Mitbegründer der Mockumentary. Und ich habe ja jetzt selber eine halbe Mockumentary auch gedreht. Ja, The Mocker Chess, so ein bisschen das deutsche Modern Family. Ganz genau, das war die Rede. Wollte ich noch mal kurz darauf zurückkommen. Sensationell. Ist auch sehr interessant, ist auch genau die Diskussion, die wir gerade führen. Genau. Masse oder halt, wenn man vom Friotong ohne Vögel oder mit dem Vogelmann im Hintergrund. Mit meiner Ex-Freundin saß ich im Kino und ... Du kannst die ruhig Joyce nennen. Nee, mit der bin ich ja immer noch zusammen. Mit meiner Ex-Freundin war ich im Kino und die Beziehung scheiterte auch darin, dass sie ... Birdman! Dass sie Birdman nicht gut fand. Ich kann mit dir nicht lesen. Sie hat den Birdman gefögelt. Sie hat im Kino geredet, einfach so. Nee, aber die Beziehung scheiterte daran, dass sie mit dieser Entwicklung nicht wirklich klarkam. Ja, das ist interessant. Ja, Moment, also was genau, also dass du dann zu berühmt warst und zu… Genau, erkannt werden und Telefonate mit Produktionsfirmen. Kannst du noch Blu-rays denn kaufen gehen, ohne erkannt zu werden? Wahrscheinlich nicht. Naja, ich habe jetzt an der Blu-Ray tatsächlich, das war sehr peinlich, ich musste jetzt eben ein Selfie machen und stand vor Brokeback Mountain. Ich musste dann ein Selfie machen und bin dann... Ganz in der Eronikabteilung. Sehr gut, sehr gut. Seht ihr morgen in der Wilden. Ja, aber also wie oft, also wirst du einmal am Tag erkannt so, kann man das sagen? Ja, ja, ja, krass. Also Domplatte für dich kannst du ja vergessen, du kannst ja nicht drüber gehen, dann bilden sich trauen. Ja, die ganzen YouTuber da, die ganzen Longboards sind bis sie umzingelt, so im Kreis, umgefahren, so umgekehrt rum. Nee, aber also ist das ein Problem auch mit Beziehungen und so? Ja, die Brüder ist. Aber auch neue Beziehungen anzufangen oder so, also ein klassisches Groupie-Flachlegen oder so, man kennt mich schon, man hat schon ein wahnsinniges Bild davon, ist das was ein Problem ist? Groupie-Flachlegen ist kein Problem, wo ist die Frage? Ne, wir waren jetzt bei Birdman und ich saß mit meiner Freundin in Birdman und da fiel irgendwann mal der wunderschöne Satz, dass seine Ex-Frau zu ihm sagst, du verwechselst Liebe mit Anerkennung. Das ist genau mein Satz, den ich schon, ja. Das war ein Moment, wo ich als Künstler so und. Da habt ihr im Film Schluss gemacht und die letzten Minuten war nur peinlich. Sie hat mich angeguckt und hat mir so zugenickt und das war ein Moment, wo ich sagte, ja, wir sind einfach, also das ist, ich habe mich in dieser Reise, die Michael Keaton da durchgemacht hat, tatsächlich diese Zukunftsangst, die man hat und dass man denkt, man könnte, also ich könnte auch der neue Birdman sein, also Ich habe manchmal Angst, dass die Phase, in der ich jetzt bin, meine erfolgreichste ist. Und es sind ja dann immer so ein Lukes Woche und ich Viech, wie auch immer das aussieht, und ein oberkörperfreier Luke Mockridge hinter dir her schwebt. Der der grosse Rab halt einfach. Der ist nur der grosse Wock. Ja, was war da denn los, ja? Alter, aber das muss ich gerade, ich bin jetzt echt gerade ein bisschen geschockt, weil das ist genau der Satz, den ich immer sage, wenn ich versuche auszudrücken, warum es manchmal zwischenmenschlich nicht so einfach ist, weil es bei mir genau dasselbe ist. Ist es nicht bei mir auch, aber es ist doch bei jedem, ich glaube es ist bei jedem. Nein, das glaube ich nicht, das glaube ich nicht. Also ganz kurz zum Beispiel. Also meine Freundin hat ihn nicht verstanden, diesen Film und auch diesen... War es dann auch jemand, der dann irgendwie Liebeslieder geschrieben hat und vor dem Fenster deiner Angebetin gespielt hat? Also so dieses irgendwie durch Kunst und durch Entertainment versuchen? Nee, weil ich eine solche narzisstische Persönlichkeitsstörung habe, dass ich eigentlich nur mich selber liebe. Nur vor dem Spiegelspiel. Ja, nie jemand anderen geliebt. Ich habe tatsächlich wenig Frauen geliebt in meinem Leben. Das ist auch so ein Ding. Ich war auch nie verknallt in der Schule. Moment, du warst nie verknallt, was ist das für eine Aussage? Nee, nie wirklich, nee, weil ich einfach zu sehr mit mir selber beschäftigt war. Aber du warst in der Schulzeit, du warst schon jemals verknallt. Ich war schon verknallt, aber das lasst das viermal, fünfmal, also das wird so die Überschrift der Folge, das wird so die Überschrift. Krass, ja, also weil ich tatsächlich sehr viel mit mir selber zu tun habe und immer eigentlich ein bisschen in der Schulzeit auch ein bisschen introvertiert war und ja, auch diese Sandwich-Kind-Konstellation war. Ich bin ja Dritter aus sechs und das hat mich auch... In einer Familie, wo alle erfolgreich sind. Ja, und ich war immer der Unerfolgreichste auch in meiner Familie. Mein kleiner Bruder war 13, als ich 17 war und der hat schon Kinofilme gedreht und alle meine Freunde haben mich gefragt, ey der eine ist in der Boyband, also mein ältester Bruder war tatsächlich auch in der Boyband, die er auch Erfolg hatte. Roses? Ne, Partzix. Partzix tatsächlich. Und dann hieß es, ja was machst du eigentlich, ne? Deine Brüder sind so gut, was machst du eigentlich? Mein Konter immer, ja ich bin so ein Versager, ich häng mit euch ab. Ah, okay, dann entwickelt sie die Comedy-Schiene. Ich warache dafür, dass ihr euch wichtig fühlt. Als Selbstschutz fängst du dann an, dich über die Situation lustig zu machen und das kristallisiert sich dann raus. Aber das kannst du ja jetzt auch nutzen, diesen Impuls, nur dass du jetzt quasi, dass die Leute, die dich ansprechen, halt nicht auf deine Brüder ansprechen, sondern auf Jan Böhmermann oder so. Und vielleicht kannst du dann irgendwann auch sagen, gut, vielleicht entwickelst du dann auch so einen Selbstschutz und wirst dann auch zu so einem. Kann sein, also ich überlege auch, was ich schreibe ja eigentlich jeden Tag und ich finde die Thematik Angst und Schwäche, finde ich, faszinierendes Comedy-Thema, weil... Der Ursprung geht ja Comedy, würde ich sagen. Ja, Wahrheit und Schmerz, du nimmst wahre Begebenheiten und es kann... Schmerzmerz plus Zeit. Das ist die Comedy-Faulie, ja. Paragödie plus zeit, gleich Komödie. Und das kann im Kleinen sein wie auf einer Party, dass du mit keinem reden kannst. Ich meine, die Situation kennt jeder, dass du abseits einer Party, und was hat man gemacht vor der Zeit von Smartphones? Ich meine, heutzutage guckst du auf den Smartphones. Und vor Serien vor allem. Und vor Siri. Ich kann es ja mit Siri. Aber es ist ja, glaube ich, doppelt peinlich, wenn du der Entertainer, der beruflich Leute unterhält, ist in einem sozialen Rahmen nicht hinbekommen. Also ich glaube, das ist natürlich für Betrachter. Das kennen wir doch auch. Als Comedy-Autor bist du mal angesprochen, ja, erzähl doch mal einen Witz. Nee, aber als Comedy-Autor geht niemand davon aus, dass du spontan lustig bist. Das ist nicht deine Aufgabe. Du gehst nicht zu Matthäus hin und sagst, hier gib mir mal einen geilen Psalm. Das funktioniert nicht. Komisches Beispiel. Nein, also ich glaube, als Entertainer, als Bühnenpersönlichkeit. Ist noch was anderes, aber als Comedy-Autor denkt, aber das ... Ich weiß, als Comedy-Autor bist Stefan. Das war auch wichtig, dass du fertig war. Das war nicht der Deal. Nur weil du ein riesiges T-Shirt hast, auf dem Comedy steht, heißt das nicht, dass jeder so laut merkt, dass es ... Ein T-Shirt, 100% Comedy. Haben wir einen Öffner? Nein. Oh nee, sorry, wir dachten, du bist studentisch genug, dass du das mit einem Feuerzeug aufmachen kannst. Du musst doch auch wenn man ein bisschen Zähnen aufmachen kann. Ich habe leider keinen Feuerzeug mit, weil ich nicht rauche. Sorry. Aber klar, da ist es natürlich doppelt unangenehm, als der Lustige dann auf einer Party nicht Anklang zu finden. Man stellt natürlich auch an sich selbst dann irgendwie Erwartungen und denkt sich so, das ist eigentlich mein Job so, aber man will ja dann auch mal vielleicht nicht lustig sein oder sowas. In der Tat, ja. Ich bin auch in meiner Gruppe Freundin nicht immer der Lustigste. Das ist aber auch völlig in Ordnung. Wer ist der Lustigste, Jules? Ach, Jules ist toll. Stefan Raab. Stefan Raab ist wahnsinnig lustig. Stefan Raab ist privat auch nicht der Lustigste. Also es geht nicht immer einen her. Johann König ist auch ein sehr in sich gekehrter, kritisierter. Aber dem atmen wir uns ja, weil er auf der Bühne auch nicht so ist, dass er Hey Leute, Dags! Ich glaube, viele Komedien sind im echten Leben gar nicht immer, weil viele sind schüchtern, die dann den Kick suchen. Auch wenn du auf der Bühne bist, hast du, wenn du auf einer Party bist, hast du ja immer die Wahl, bin ich jetzt extrovertiert oder nicht. Auf der Bühne hast du diese Wahl nicht. Und deswegen wirst du gezwungen, dahin zu gehen, wo es eigentlich wehtut und holst dir da, tankst dann da. Und Leute hören dir zu, die müssen dir zuhören, sonst. Sie haben dafür gezahlt, dass sie dir zuhören. Sie haben dafür gezahlt, dass sie dir zuhören. Das ist schon eine ganz gute Situation eigentlich. Ich würde sagen, das ist die beste Situation. Oder halt auch die schlimmste. Du kannst einen Therapeuten dafür bezahlen, dass er dir zuhört, oder du lässt dich sehr gut bezahlen, dass er 1.000 Leute zuhört. Ist aber interessant, dieses Konzept Stand-Up-Comedy als Therapie haben glaube ich schon viele Leute genannt, dass man einfach so ein bisschen von der Seele reden kann. Also ich meine, du spielst ja auch so ein bisschen mit deinem, also ich würde ganz gerne über deine Comedy-Persona sprechen. Die du dir ausgedacht hast, am Schreibtisch ausgedacht hast. Du bist ja nicht derselbe wie auf der Bühne, also du spielst schon, also du bist einerseits, ich finde es ganz interessant, weil du machst so diesen Spagat zwischen ich bin schon der Coole, weißt du, ich kann singen, ich kann tanzen, ich kann alles, aber ich bin auch ein bisschen so tollpatschig, schon so ein bisschen der Schlags, ich mache mich auch zum Dumm. Also dann, wenn du ... Ja, ich versuche, ich bin ein sehr, eigentlich von Natur aus, ein sehr verkopfter Typ.
Und auf der, und ich hasse das, was heißt ich hasse das, aber mir missfällt das an mir.
Also ich liebe immer Leute, die, die in den Raum kommen und dann beginnt ihre Show. Also so Leute, die so, ey, boi, boi, boi, boi, boi, so und Stefan Titzel zum Beispiel. Stefan Titzel. Aber die kriegen ja Leute oft in ihren Bann, also diese extrovertierten Persönlichkeiten, die in einen Raum reinkommen und alle, ey, was geht und hier, Gag da und ich habe eh was erlebt. Stalin zum Beispiel und sowas. Ja, das ist auch so einer. Alle lachen sich dann darüber kaputt und ich wäre gern so. Und ich glaube, es gibt so ein bisschen diese Theorie, die ich verfolge, dass ich auf der Bühne so will, was ich gerne wäre, wie ich gerne im echten Leben wäre. So wie man auf Facebook, also Facebook-Profile sind ja kein Spiegelbild deiner selbst, sondern das Spiegelbild von dem, wie du gerne wahrgenommen werden möchtest. Ja genau, wie Möbel, sag mal auch Möbel. Es ist die Werbung, es ist optimale Werbung. Wie Möbel? Weiß nicht, ich habe immerhin was zu tun. Oder wie Möbel. Ich habe gehofft, ich habe nicht zu. Ich glaube, Facebook ist das. Wir einigen uns auf Möwen, weil es so halb Sinn ergeben. Ne, Möbel, mit Möbel kannst du dich auch ausdrücken. Die Diskussion hatten wir auch mal im Vorfeld. Ah, das ist schön. Das war unser schlechtester Podcast über Möbel und du referentierst jetzt überöbel-Podcast. Ja, deswegen ist die ganze Zeit beim Kopf gestickt so, da geht es ja dran.
Du machst dich ja schon über dich selbst lustig, aber nicht so ganz knallhart dann doch so.
Du bist auch in deiner Ich-bin-der-doofe-Schlags dann doch noch irgendwie doch noch der Coole irgendwie so.
Ich kann zu einem Grad über mich lachen, wo es akzeptabel ist, aber du bist nicht ein Louis C.K., der erzählt, wie er irgendwie seine absoluten sexuellen Rockbottoms hat und irgendwie erzählt hat, wie eine Frau in Tränen ausbricht, nachdem sie mit ihm geschlafen hat, weil das die schlimmste Erfahrung der Welt war für diese Frau. So weit gehst du dann doch nicht zu. Und wie er in seiner eigenen Scheisse mit seinen Kindern liegt. Ich würde auch denken, wenn er das in Deutschland gemacht hätte, dann wäre das aber auch eine grössere Nummer gewesen. Das wäre nicht so geil gefunden worden. Ja, Louis C.K. ist irgendwie tragisch und ich bin wahrscheinlich, also mir würde man, wenn ich jetzt so eine Nummer machen würde.
In deine eigenen Scheisse zu liegen.
Ja, das würde mir keiner, also das würde nicht, ich wüsste jetzt nicht den Anker, wie man das performt, dass das funktioniert.
Ja, dass man da wieder rauskommt.
Ja, dass das lustig wird, weil es einfach, ich finde, Comedy muss immer, also ich erzähle ja kaum Gags, also ich weiß nicht, ob ihr mein Material wirklich kennt, es geht wirklich nur über Wahrheit von einem bestimmten Blickwinkel beleuchtet. Also du nimmst eine Alltagssituation und … Die bestenfalls jeder kennt. Die bestenfalls jeder kennt. Ein Gag, der immer funktioniert bei mir, ist, du darfst in Deutschland erst legal Sex haben, das ist wirklich das Gesetz, du darfst in Deutschland erst legal Sex haben mit 16, das ist das Gesetz. Du kannst aber unter Umständen, und das ist wirklich das Gesetz, schon mit 14 Sex haben, wenn man eine schriftliche Einwilligung der Eltern hat. Das ist einfach nur ein Fakt, den sag ich so und kriegst Lacher schon so. Ja, schon, weil du hast sofort Kopfkino, wie du irgendwie Sex haben willst und deine Mutter steht neben dir und unterschreibt einen Vertrag, du hast sofort ein Bilden bekommen. Das finde ich ist die wahre Comedy, wenn du einfach die Wahrheit in der perfekten Anzahl und mit dem perfekten Vokabular so wiedergibst, dass die Leute sagen, fuck, ist das geil, stimmt. Das ist so mein Anspruch. So ein Jerry Seinfeld, der ist dann noch breit getreten dann wahrscheinlich. Also der richtige Observational-Comedian, der kann noch breit treten und so. Jerry Seinfeld ist natürlich in der Observation ein Weltmeister, der ist aber auch sehr breit und auch sehr massenkompatibel, weil die Wahrheit kennt jeder. Ich finde Wahrheit immer lustig. Ich lache, wenn ich selber Comedians mir angucke, liebe ich Leute wie Olli Polak oder Ingmar Stadelmann, die so ekelhaft auf die Fresse hauen, wo mein Publikum teilweise, wenn die bei Nightbrush auftreten, verschämt weggucken, aber das finde ich dann geil. Weil es einfach eine andere Peergroup ist, in der du wahrscheinlich. Ja, weil ich mich selber nicht trauen würde. Also Olli Bohler stand mal bei uns und sagte, ja, ich habe mir jetzt einen Germanwings-Adventskalender geholt, da gehen die Türchen nicht auf. Jesus, ja, und alle so, und das war halt irgendwie vor drei Tagen gewesen, das Unglück, und ich habe mich kaputt gemacht. Ja, kann man aber auch, dem kann man auch vorwerfen, das ist blanke Provokationen. Man kann eigentlich jedem was vorwerfen. Ja, man kann schon jedem irgendwie was vorwerfen. Du kannst der ankommt, sucht, der findet. Du kannst jedem, der ankommt, vorwerfen, warum er ankommt. Genau so einem Jan Böhmermann könnte man ja auch eigentlich vorwerfen, dass er eigentlich nur geliebt werden möchte. Also den Eindruck hat man manchmal so als Zuschauer, dass man einfach sagt so, ja, entspann dich, alles gut, wir finden nicht alle genial, alles cool. Aber er könnte es sich ja auch leichter machen, er könnte ja auch irgendwie, sag ich mal, politische Meinung vertreten, die die Masse vertritt, oder er könnte ja Dinge auch auf die offensichtliche Art irgendwie behandeln. Was er dann doch immer nicht macht, er nimmt dann doch oft die Position ein irgendwie für den rationalen, über dem Problem hafischen. Oder die Metaebene der Metaebene der Metaebene der Metaebene. Ja, genau, aber die Metaebene der Metaebene der Metaebene verwässert dann deine eigene Mitte, finde ich ich. Wenn du auf drei Leveln Inception-mäßig unterwegs bist, dann weisst du gar nicht, welcher ist der Ursprungstraum. Ist es der mit dem Snowboards und dem Schnee oder sind wir jetzt in dem Bus, der oft von der Brücke... Was mich vorgestört hat, das sind Grossteil der Filme dieser langweiligen Eiswüste auf Hot quasi. Naja, natürlich. Dem dritten Planeten des Sternensystems Hot. Ja,, Inception furchtbar. Die Frage, die Florian eigentlich noch stellen wollte, wir wollen ja auch langsam mit Stand-Up anfangen. Wir haben beide auch Bock, mal ein bisschen mit Stand-Up zu machen. Wollt ihr wirklich? Ja, schon. Also wir haben auch noch einen Termin. Hast du die Maxi-Stand-Bauer-Folge zu Ende gehört? Ich bin gejumpt. Da hab ich ja, wann reden sie über mich, da hab ich... Ohne Scheiss! Da siehst du, wie narzisstisch persönlichkeitsgestört ich eigentlich bin.
Ja, genau.
Bin ich dann erwähnt worden in dem Podcast?
Doch, doch, ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube nach der Aufzeichnung kann man noch sehr lange über die Aufzeichnung.
Bis eben.
Nee, aber da habe ich fünf Minuten vorbereitet tatsächlich, einfach mal um eine Deadline zu haben, zu sagen, zu dem Termin will ich fünf Minuten haben und habe die ganze am Ende vorgetragen, was mega uncool war, weil Maxi war schon weg. Er hat nämlich, Maxi Schlenburg hat nicht erlaubt, dass er es macht. Also er hat sich, er hat sich, er hat sich, er hat sich, er hat sich, er hat sich, er hat sich, er hat sich, er hat sich, er hat sich, erbauer, damit er mir Feedback geben kann und zu sagen, das war gut und was schlecht, damit man sich mal reinzuhauen. Und er hat gesagt, nee, das würde dir eh nichts helfen, das musst du vor Publikum machen, hat es abgelehnt, was ja auch in Ordnung ist. Dann dann habe ich ganz am Schluss nochmal die fünf Minuten gemacht, um es zu machen. Ist natürlich vor einer anderen Person, die irgendwie auf die Uhr guckt und weg will, ist halt natürlich nicht ganz so die ganze Situation. Aber nee, also um darauf zu kommen, wir haben jetzt auch einen Termin in einem Open Mic in Köln. Welcher? Kunstgegenbares oder wo sei es? Boing. Im Boing Club. Das einzige, was wir bekommen haben. Der einzige, der Blick, der Blick, aber genau. viel Spaß und tschau. Das ist eine sehr laute Kaffeemaschine, die bei Boing immer in die Sets... Vor allem ist es auch immer so ein sympathischer Feedback-Ton, der die ganze Zeit kontinuierlich durch das Mikro läuft, wo man denkt die ganze Zeit, fuck. Der DJ der immer, Don't drink a drive. Ja, aber wir wollen genauer, was wollen Sie zwei Bier und man ist immer viel zu laut. Ja, dann erzähl doch mal, was sind denn eure Gags, wo habt ihr denn schon irgendwas? Also, erzähl doch mal eine, einfach mal eine, oder nur eine Beobachtung, die du hattest. Ich finde ja Beobachtungen immer spannender. Du siehst aus wie Matthias Oppenhövel, jetzt fällt es mir auf, oder? Tatsächlich. Weiß ich nicht, das hat man noch nicht immer gesagt. Nee? Als Nils Burkelberg hier hat man mir gesagt, ich sehe aus wie Nils Burkelberg. Es ist immer, glaube ich, die Person. Ich glaube, Nils Burkelberg sagt jedem Menschen, dass er aussieht. Ich glaube, man sieht mir sehr viel. Er hat einfach keinen Spiegel. Man sieht mir, glaube ich, mehrere andere Leute. Aber Opnöfel doch tatsächlich, ja. Weil die Brille dreht. Ja, wahrscheinlich, ja. Und die schwarzen Haare. Mehr ist es ja. Also, Gags, her damit. Ich fange mal an. Ich habe, als ich einfach Stand-up schreiben wollte, zum ersten Mal so ein paar fünf Minuten. Die ersten fünf Minuten sind ja immer sauschwer, die zusammenzustellen. Da habe ich mal einfach aus Spaß, weil ich mir dachte, vielleicht bringt es ja einen Gag, bei Google angegeben, was man machen sollte, wie man am besten Stand-up schreiben sollte. Und da gab es eine Liste, wo drei Gründe genannt wurden, wie man Stand-up schreiben sollte. Und der erste Grund war, der erste Weg war, sei lustig, der zweite Weg war, respektiert das Handwerk und der dritte Weg, was für mich sehr interessant war, weil ich jetzt zum ersten Mal was machen wollte, war benutze niemals neues Material. Ja, und das wäre der erste Gag. So wollte ich quasi einsteigen, aber da dachte ich mir, es ist gar nicht so eine schlechte Beobachtung. Aber es ist natürlich eine sehr spezielle Beobachtung. Man spielt mit der Situation, dass man gerade zum ersten Mal auf der Bühne ist, dass man zum ersten Mal Stand-Up macht, das verwurzelt man gerade. Man verwurzelt die Gunst des Moments, dass man zum ersten Mal auf der Bühne steht mit dem Gag. Und man macht einen Gag, der neu ist, obwohl der Gag impliziert, dass man... Was sagst du? Rauschmeißen oder behalten? So als Opener. Als Opener ist es natürlich... Ja, es ist natürlich Selbstreferenzialität. Ja, genau. Und das ist, glaube ich, die Leute... Hassen das. Also, ich bin immer ein Riesenfan davon, erstmal rauszugehen und sagen, hallo, ich bin... Und irgendein Loch in einem Gag. Und irgendein Loch in einem Gag. Wahrscheinlich immer zum Namen, viele fangen an und sagen, mein Name ist so und so und so und so und so und haben dann dazu einen Gag. Mario Barth. Ja, beispielsweise. Okay, warte, dann kann ich einen sagen, die du lest mir einen sagen? Ja, klar. Der erste Gag, mit dem du angefangen hast. Nee, nee, ein anderer, ein anderer. Hallo, mein Name ist Flontien Will, ich bin Stand-Up-Kopinion, ich bin hier, um Sie zum Lachen zu bringen. Jetzt schon eine Eins, super. Wenn Sie nicht lachen, haben Sie umsonst bezahlt. So, los geht's. Also, ich tue mir immer recht schwer auf Dates, weil ich immer nicht genau weiss, irgendwie, wie wird sich die Beziehung entwickeln. Man will ja immer wissen, mag mich die Frau jetzt, aber sie soll mich ja auch mögen, wenn ich mich verändere. Ich will ja ein bisschen gucken, wie kann es in der Zukunft aussieht. Deswegen mache ich immer folgendes, ich bringe immer die gleiche Hose fünfmal mit in unterschiedlichen Grössen. Und jedes Mal, wenn ich aufs Klo gehe, ziehe ich eine etwas kleinere Stufe an, einfach um zu sehen, will die Frau auch noch was mit mir zu tun haben, wenn ich fetter bin, so dass ich während des Dates immer fetter bin. Vielleicht schwer zu verstehen, glaube ich, weil die aber machen wir es denn. Beide, nur ein ... Ganz kurz. Nein, also die Grundidee ist ... Wenn du zwei Booster in der drinnen interessiert ... Wieses, lass mich doch mal erklären jetzt ... Nein, ich arbeite nur inhaltlich daran, das war jetzt an der Performance noch nicht. Also die Idee ist, dass du auf den Dates ganz oft dieselbe Hose mitnimmst, in unterschiedlichen Grössen, und dann alle halbe Stunde eine etwas kleinere Hose anziehst, damit es so aussieht, als würdest du während dem Date immer fetter werden. Hat auf jeden Fall einen absolut hohen Identifikationsfaktor mit dem Publikum. Ich glaube, das ist eine Situation, die kennt jeder, die hat jeder mal gemacht. Und also ich jetzt als jemand, der immer ein Wir-Gefühl etablieren möchte. Ich habe wahnsinnige Schweissausbrot, das ist so ein fucking Stress. Ja, auf die Bühne zu erzählen, auf die Bühne zu kommen und Gags zu erzählen, das ist so eine komische, weirde Situation. Vor allem, ich habe mich auch da schon zweimal versprochen. Die unwahrscheinlichen Ereignisse war so eine Sketch-Comedy, die wir produziert haben, wo ich auch im Ensemble war. Und da war es Casting und da sollten wir so eine kleine Szene spielen und ich hatte wirklich, jeder hatte so einen kleinen Abschnitt und ich hatte einen Abschnitt mit einer Pointe. Und ich habe genau das Wort, das die Pointe war, beim ersten Mal versprochen. Ja, super.
Und dann, nee, wir machen die Szenen nochmal, beim zweiten Mal habe ich genau das gleiche Wort auf genau die gleiche Art nochmal versprochen. Und dann war es lustig. Wo ich mir dachte, nee, aber überhaupt nicht lustig, weil natürlich die anderen nicht gelacht haben, weil sie den Job selber haben wollen. So, wo ich mir dachte, okay, ciao, ich bin raus hier, macht's gut, ich bin dafür einfach nicht gemacht, weil dann immer genau das Wort, das man haben will, nicht funktioniert. Hat nicht funktioniert, lass mich in einen anderen Gag machen, über den wir schon mal gesprochen hatten. Also, es ist halt der etablierende Moment zu sagen, ich habe fünf verschiedene Hosen und jedes Mal bei einem Date, das ist halt, ich glaube, das ist schwer nachzuvollziehen, ja. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr Christian Kokol kennt? Nee. Das war ein sehr stranger, weirder Comedian aus Krefeld, der ähnliche Setups immer hatte, der hatte einfach völlig verrückte Setups, also die Situation, die Etablierung der Situation immer hatte, wo keiner was mit anfangen kann.
Aber er hat das so lustig erzählt, dass das auch wieder funktioniert hat. Also das kann, wenn das sein Stil ist, dass du merkwürdige, ey, kennt ihr das, wenn man bei einem Date und für eine Posen...
Lass mich noch einen versuchen, lass mich noch einen versuchen.
Aber nicht so etwas Kompliziertes wieder, aber ich muss mal nachdenken.
Okay, ich stand letztens an der Ampel und ich glaube, die Situation kennt jeder. In jeder Gruppe, die an der Ampel wartet, gibt es immer diesen einen Typen, der an dem Ampel-Drücker rumdrückt, obwohl da überhaupt kein Knopf ist. Die Ampel läuft automatisch, aber es gibt immer einen, der drückt auf der Ampel rum, versucht aus jedes Element irgendwie durchzudrücken, ob man da irgendwo einen kleinen Schalter aufgehen machen kann, wo man noch ein Ampelmännchen freischalten kann. Drückt er überall rum, und er drückt da rum, obwohl es da nicht mal irgendwie einen Knopf gibt, auf den man drücken kann. Also falls ihr ungefähr wissen wollt, wie mein erstes Mal lief, genau so. Das war okay. Das war gut. Dankeschön! Nicht zu lachen. Kein Lacher, kein Lacher. Aber das sind Comedians. Comedians lachen nicht. Ja, das ist die Medians, die nur so, funktioniert nicht. Das war mir auch so unangenehm, als ich das erste Mal in Boeing war, das ist so uncool, dass du sagen, das ist so uncool, aber da war ich das erste Mal da, weil ich mein Kumpel hatte, da war erst mal Stand-up gemacht, ja, und danach war dann irgendwie so ein Get-together der Comedians, die da aufgetreten sind. Das kenne ich nicht. Und ich bin da da geblieben, weil ich mir dachte, ich frage mal nach einem Termin, und es war so unangenehm, weil ich bin da so ein Typ, ich will dann einfach da auch abliefern, und denke mir, das sind Comedians, du willst hier was machen, da musst du auch lustig sein, da jetzt, und die lachen einfach nicht. Das ist so unangenehm, damit komme ich überhaupt gar nicht klar. Komedians lachen nicht, ne. Das ist so unangenehm. Comedians haben auch einen absolut schlimmen Galgenhumor und Backstage mit Comedians ist das hart. Ziemlich anstrengend, ja. Aber ganz kurz nochmal, der war okay, damit kann man was machen. Der war lustig, weil es erstmal die Situation anspricht, die jeder kennt. Jeder kennt den Typen an der Ampel, ist genau der gleiche Typ, der mehrmals die Aufzugtaste drückt, wo man sagt, kommt der Aufzug jetzt schneller, wenn du dreimal drückst? Der auch im Pokercenter immer zu oft auf A gedrückt hat. Im Pokercenter, weil man schneller unten die Leiste, ja, absolut nicht schlecht. Oder der beim Auto bei der Gangschaltung immer vers... Oder wenn eine Frau vergewaltigt, ganz versucht, sie zu erdrosseln. Er wird langsam aus dem Reis gedrückt. Kennt ihr das, wenn man eine Frau vergewaltigt, ganz versucht sie zu erdrosseln. Kennt ihr das, wenn man eine Frau vergewaltigt und das wollte ich mal unbedingt, ich wollte unbedingt mal ein Stand-up machen mit, kennt ihr das, weil jeder fängt ja an mit Knie und dann kennst du den Linsen mal. Kennt ihr das, wenn man einen Babywelpen so quält, dass er dann so laut weint und irgendwann dann nicht mehr weint, weil er seine eigenen Schmerzen nicht mehr ertragen kann und dann ...
Und lieber gestorben ist.
Mach das doch einfach mal!
Ich glaube, da könntest du dem Luke-Mockish-Publikum mal irgendwie echt den Finger zeigen.
Wollte ich sagen, 500.000 Facebook-Likes weniger, aber Jan Böhmermann wird es feiern.
Ich finde das immer lustig, wenn du das immer ... Du könntest dich auch sehr gut mit deiner Person erbrechen, glaube ich.
Vor allem, wenn du gerade in so einer Phase bist, wo du nicht genau weißt, wo du hin willst, ist es, glaube ich, ganz geil, mal so ein bisschen drum zu probieren und zu merken, welches Publikum hast du nur wegen der Gummibärchen-Gags, Gummibärenbandel-Gags. Ja, wahrscheinlich viele. Ja, aber wenn du die loswerden willst, geht das, glaube ich, sehr einfach, indem du sagst, habt ihr schon mal Hundewelpen gequält, hä, hä? Ja, ich habe das mal auf YouTube gemacht, wir haben mal so ein YouTube-Video, das kam furchtbar an. Wir haben eine Top-10-Verarschung gemacht, kennt wir haben gemacht zehn Dinge, die jeder kennt. Auf Platz zehn Tisch, auf Platz neun Tisch Kante, auf Platz acht Tisch Bein. Und dann haben wir noch als Extra-Republik zehn Zahlen zwischen eins und zehn, die jeder kennt, und dann haben wir auf Platz zehn die vier, auf Platz neun die neun, auf Platz acht die vier. Und das kam das hatten die Leute, also deswegen sage ich, dieser Meta-Meta-Ebenen-Humor, den Leute feiern, die selber in den Medien, also man kann entweder, man macht Comedy für DWDL oder man macht Comedy für den Rest von Deutschland. Und ich glaube, diesen Spagat muss man sich irgendwie, muss man sie erlauben oder man findet wirklich einen goldenen Weg in der Mitte. Also, DWDL ist auch ein sehr spannendes Thema. Fand deine Serie sehr gut. Ja, finden mich aber scheisse. Ja, aber die fanden mich scheisse. Jetzt nicht mehr. DWDL schreibt mich immer in den Keller. Aber du spielst bei der Serie nur mit oder bist du da auch als Autor? Ich schreibe da auch mit. Ach, okay, cool, schreibst du nicht also im Team, oder? Ja, ja. Schreibst du dann einzelne Folgen, oder ist es dann so ein Writer's Room? Es ist ein Writer's Room und es macht Ping-Bong und am Set. Die Poaten fliegen wieder an der, weil wir mal bis um drei Uhr nachts noch dringend, wir brauchen noch ein Kick, Mann. Hey, das ist okay, das ist cool, it's business. Und ja, irgendwann möchte ich aber auch mal schreiben, also mein grosser Traum ist es, irgendwann mal mit mir. Hast du schon ein Buch geschrieben? Ja, ein Buch geschrieben, tatsächlich, innerhalb von drei Wochen, das war geil. Macht ihr jetzt ein Arschloch? Ja, und es ist ein bisschen so gevorbereitet. Habt ihr es mal gelesen? Nein, natürlich nicht. Ich hätte es euch mitgebracht, es ist tatsächlich lustiger, als man es von mir erraten würde. Wirklich, weil es ist... Weißt du die Selbstironie? Ja! Da ist doch der ironische Herr, wir haben ihn rausgekitzelt. Ihr habt ihn rausgekitzelt.
War auch so arrogant, aber jetzt raus.
You created a monster.
Das ist ein wunderschönes Zitat aus einem Eminem-Lied von der zweiten Platte.
I created a monster cause nobody wants to see Marshall no more, they want Shady.
Du brauchst einen Shady vielleicht.
Wenn ich besoffen bin, dann rede ich sehr oft über dieses Eminem-Zitat, weil manchmal fühlt man sich so, dass man vielleicht einen Monster kreiert hat. Oder kreieren möchte. Oder ja. Oder auch mal, du warst bis jetzt immer der Gute, vielleicht willst du auch mal der Böse sein. Engelchen und Teufelchen auf meiner Schulter. Engel links, Teufel rechts, rechts nimmt er die Frau. Jetzt kommen wir hier, jetzt haben wir hier Sachen. Du willst sie doch auch. Wir haben das gesungen bei Nightwash, das Publikum konnte zu 100% das Text. Alle, jeder kannte jedes Wort in diesem Lied. Aber das tatsächlich, muss ich auch mal sagen, das war einer meiner Momente, wo ich mich noch nie so cool gefühlt habe. Ich glaube, es war das dritte Mal, dass ich beim Neo Magazin war und das noch hier in dem kleinen Studio. Ich total verschüchtert, Angst, glaube ich, ich habe keinen einzigen Satz mit Jan Böhrmann gewechselt zu dem Zeitpunkt und komplett verschüchtert und dann irgendwie, Jan war kurz vorm Warm-up und dann waren wir alle noch in der Regie irgendwie so, alle Vorbereitungen, Publikum war da, man hört das Duschen und so und dann irgendjemand, ich weiss nicht, ob es Jan war oder so, fängt an, es ist 1996 und langsam Stück für Stück fängt jeder in der Regie an mitzusehen. So, weisst du, wie man das nennt? Den kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner. Das ist Luke-Mockridge-Moment. Das ist der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner und das ist das Wir-Gefühl und dieses Gefühl kriegt man bei mir zweieinhalb Stunden auf der Bühne, wenn man sich... Ihr habt das gesehen, Sie sind für die... Nein, nein, nein, das geht nicht. Aber ihr habt den Stand-up gesehen und diesen Moment, wo ich das singe und das Publikum das komplett mitsingt, begeistert und mitklatscht, war das, wo ihr denkt, ist das aber ein bisschen billig oder ist das erst billig, wenn man die Karriere in dem Verlauf erst beobachtet? Ich habe ganz gehauten Ständer bekommen. So, aber ich dachte, es ist ein bisschen billig, muss ich ganz ehrlich zugeben, weil ich mir dachte, so von wegen, ja, dass ich das auch noch hinbekomme. Aber ist das nicht ein Lied, was jeder kennt, aber woran bestimmt man zehn bis zwölf Jahre nicht mehr daran gedacht hat und auf einmal wird eine Synapse freigeschaltet. Ja, das ist halt Unterhaltung aber einfache, ich will Comedians sehen, die Dinge machen, die ich nicht hinbekommen hätte. Ich will, dass er Pointen präsentiert, auf die ich nicht gekommen wäre. Da sagt er, fuck, Alter, da würde ich auch gerne drauf kommen. Ja, aber das ist, weil du auch im Business bist, weil du auch jetzt auf die Bühne möchtest und weil du Comedians sehen möchtest, die dich überraschen. Als Konsument ist es glaube ich. Aber ich denke mir, es ist ja nicht schwer, diesen gemeinsamen Nenner zu finden. Ich kann ja auch auf die Bühne gehen und sagen, ey Montage, Alter, oder gibt's was Nervigeres als Montage und du hast sofort einen Applaus. Wo ich mir denke, das kriegt jeder hin, das kriegt jeder Depp hin. Oder noch nicht, vielleicht ist da auch eine Kunst dahinter, die ich einfach nicht verstehe. Oder vielleicht wirkt es einfach so einfach. Ja, das ist die grosse Kunst. Genau, deswegen kommt Simon Desu zu uns in den Wachst, Scheiße, jetzt habe ich den Namen gesagt. Oh! Der piept den eben, der piept den eben, der piept den eben nach Simon Desu. Deswegen kommt der in den Waschsalon, denkt er kann's und fällt damit auf die, weil es eben nicht so einfach ist. Können wir das Gespräch nochmal führen, nachdem wir unsere ersten fünf Minuten hatten, vielleicht? Also vielleicht sollten wir nochmal... Wir nehmen die ersten fünf Minuten noch auf und können sie dir schicken, dass du gerne ein kleines Feedback gibst, weil wir brauchen glaube ich die Hilfe, die wir kriegen können. Ja, vielleicht für Nightwush, wir wollen uns einfach bewerben dann für Nightwush irgendwann mal. Ja, wir sollten vielleicht erst mal ein bisschen üben. Wer hört uns eigentlich? Meine Mutter und seine Tante. Gibt's Aufrufzahlen? Ja, gibt es, aber wir haben keine Ahnung, was hier zu bedeuten. Also wir haben auch viel Twitter-Traffic, wenn ihr da... Wir haben 1400 Follower auf Twitter. Wir hatten aber im September, was auch immer das heissen mag, 300.000 Aufrufe. Was? Auf unserer Seite! Wir kriegen immer Statistiken vom Server und haben keine Ahnung, was es ist. Da stehen irgendwelche wahnsinnig grossen Megabyte-Zahlen und Aufrufe, aber wir wissen nicht, sind es irgendwelche Spam-Accounts, es ist iTunes, die auf die Seite zugreifen. Ja, aber vielleicht sollten wir das einfach mal Werbe, KitKat schicken zum Beispiel und sagen, wir würden auch KitKat-Werbung machen. Wie kommen wir an einen KitKat-Deal ran? Oder Booster, das ist schon Booster reichen, diese klinische Firma, die gefährliche Drinks macht, das würde es auch schon reichen. Müsst ihr in die Hölle reisen, um Nestle. Du kennst einen guten Eingang, glaube ich. Absolut, ja. Über das TV-Total-Studio, kennt ihr diese Hebebühne, die hochgeht? Das ist der Eingang zur Hölle, wo Rab immer hochkommt. Ja, ja. Nehmt man die auch nicht? Als Comedian geht man dann von rechts kommt man rein. Richtig, rechts über die Seite. Und mein erster TV-Total-Auftritt war unglaublich. War der auch scheisse, wie alle anderen Comedians versagen. War der auch scheisse, wie in einem anderen Auftritt. Nee, aber da war es natürlich ganz okay und hatte danach sechstausend Likes, was dann so unglaublich war. Sechstausend Gummibärchen-Fans. Nee, da habe ich über die Schule gesprochen. Sechstausend Schüler. Sie sind da draußen. Und mein schlimmster Gedanke war, fall nicht die Treppe runter. Das war das, was in meinem Kopf war, fall nicht. Der Jennifer Lawrence-MomentMoment. Aber da hättest du vielleicht 8000 Follower gehabt. Irgendwann ist das Rausch. Das ist Jan Böhrmann, der gerade auf seinem Firmen-Longboard da nach Hause fährt. So ein Start-Mikro kommt hier hochgefahren. Ich hätte fast den Longboard-Führerschein-Gag gemacht. Ich hasse ja Running Gags. Das ist auch so ein Ding. Ich meine, wir sind arrogante Arschlöcher. Das ist wahr. Deswegen so diese ganzen einfachen Dinge aus Running Gags. Wir haben zwar im Podcast einige, aber es ist immer, es ist so einfach irgendwie. Ich weiß nicht, ich habe dann doch... Running Gags sind einfach? Ja. Ja, gut. Ich glaube, es gibt... Ja, weißt du, zum Beispiel, wo ich sagte, Jan Böhmann macht seinen Longboard-Führerscheiden. Weißt du, das ist ein Running Gag, der kommt ständig, bei jedem Neo-Magazin-Posting kommen ständig diese ganzen Gags. Ja, aber es ist ja dieses Helfatoire, was du dir irgendwann... Irgendwann, glaube ich... Ja, aber es ist halt auch irgendwie so... Man muss das Rad aber auch nicht immer neu erfinden, ne? Wenn die Leute lachen, hast du meistens Recht. Na, boah, das weiss ich nicht. Aber das ist halt so deine Philosophie. Na gut, aber demnach wäre Hitler ja auch ein guter Staatsmann, weil alle gesagt haben... Oh, die Nazi-Keule, die Eva-Hermann-Zurzung. Die Nestle-Keule, die Nestle-Keule. Jedes Argument kannst du mit Hitler kaputt machen, wenn man das irgendwie dreht.
Man kann alles nicht mehr drehen und wenden.
Ich glaube, es gibt immer andere.
Aber ganz kurz zum Beispiel.
Ja.
Kennst du diesen Pick-up-Artist, The Devil Method?
Nee, aber ich weiss, was Pick-up-Artist ist.
Er darfst du auch nicht Pick-up sagen, ich weiss es nicht.
Oh, hey, oh, nicht schlecht!
Comedy-File an einem Stunden und der Herr hat ein richtig gute Gagges-File.
Wenn man die Fresse ist. Nicht schlecht, war echt gut, war echt gut. Showende, Showende. Wir können jetzt Werbung machen, die Leute würden dranbleiben. Auf jeden Fall. Jetzt hören sie drei Minuten KitKat-Werbung. Unser Musik-Act kommt jetzt. Und der hat, über den machen sie alle lustig, weil der ist ein absoluter Douchebag und hat total beschessene Werbzwege. Wo waren wir denn gerade? Wir heilen sie auch nicht mehr, wo wir waren. Bei Pickup-Arters. Ich wollte gerade anfangen mit Pickup-Arters. Mach den Running-Gag, mach den Gag nochmal, dann ist es... Stefan Titzel ist hier. Wiederhol ihn, wiederhol ihn, wiederhol ihn. Der mit dem Pickup-Gagler. Genau, wiederhol ihn. Und der sieht immer total scheisse aus, hat total beschissene Kleidung. Der hat ein Video gemacht und hat gesagt, ja, ich suche meine Kleidung nicht selber aus, ich gehe zu einer Frau und sage, was gefällt dir an Männern und kleide mich an. Mir ist es scheissegal, was ich selber anhabe, Hauptsache es funktioniert bei Frauen. Der hat also diese ganze knallharte whatever works strategie und er sieht natürlich total scheiße aus und er hat so einen kragen den er nach oben gestellt hat aber so ein offenes jakett und wo du denkst welche frauen sind das denn eigentlich die sowas mögen aber dem der hat einfach keinen eigenen stil der hat einfach nichts wo er sagt dass es sein soll er lässt sich komplett von äußeren umständen liefern von den frauen die sagen was funktioniert hey der gibt ihnen fünf parfum sagt welches magst am liebsten und das trägt er, egal ob es ihm selber gefällt oder nicht. Und das funktioniert für ihn total gut, alle machen es sich wieder lustig, weil es total scheisse aussieht, aber in seiner Welt, in den Frauen, die er haben möchte, funktioniert es total gut. Also er reisst damit Frauen auf. Er reisst damit Frauen auf, aber das ist für mich so die Die meisten Pickup-Artists auf YouTube sind Fake. Ja? Ja. Ja, aber die fällt sehr oft auf solche Maschen rein. Ich bin abhängig von diesen, ich brauche diese Leute. Hast du auch dem Mulumbubumbu 500 Euro nach Ghana überwiesen, weil er Sohn eines Prinzen ist? Habe ich verdammt nochmal. Er ist einer von den Typen, der immer den Frauen schreibt, auch Pornoseiten, die ihm dann schreiben. Live Jasmine, hast du schon mit livejasmine.com gewebcampt? Klar, das ist meine beste Freundin, wir schreiben. Ja, aber das ist, finde ich, so ein Beispiel von So kann Whatever Works auch nach hinten losgehen. Wenn du dich nur von anderen Einflüssen lenken lässt und nur denkst so, oh, was Lacher generiert, das funktioniert, dann kannst du auch irgendwann, verlierst du deinen eigenen Stil und deine Persönlichkeit und bist ein Clown. Ja, das haben viele Comedians, diesen Weg haben auch viele, das ist immer so, ich mache jede Sendung, ich hüpfe in jedes Panel, ich moderiere alles, ich mache alles, ich drehe jetzt einen Film. Also viele Comedians haben den Weg gegangen und verwässern an ihr eigenes Profil. Man muss sich immer wieder die Frage stellen, wo will ich hin, wofür will ich eigentlich stehen? In der Karriere, aber auch im Leben. Also ich glaube, als Mensch, als heranwachsender Mensch. Wenn du gesagt hast, wer Lacher kriegt, hat Recht. Aber es gibt auch für dich wahrscheinlich Momente, wo du sagst, das wird jetzt funktionieren, aber mache ich nicht. Ja, bestes Beispiel, du sitzt in einem Theater, spielst dein Solo und jemand wirft eine Flasche um. Wenn du in dem Moment sagst, boah, das ist aber eine harte Kontaktlinse. Verdammt, ja. Aber ja, man macht den Gag eins zu eins genauso. Und der funktioniert jedes Mal. Und ich mache wenigstens, oh, das war ein riesen Kontakt, da sitzt Mesut Özil im Publikum. So, der Luke-Mockridge-Spin, der Luke-Mockridge-Spin und äh... Bei Flo und Tim, wir essen Wahl, Tiergags. Ja. Ey, mittlerweile machst du meine Gags schon besser als die. Ich weiss, wie hat sich dieses Gespräch entwickelt? Wie man es einfach umkrempelt. Aber ich glaube, der grosse Unterschied zwischen Comedy-Autoren und Comedians ist, dass bei euch geht es um den Inhalt und bei uns geht es mehr um die Präsentationsform. Also du kannst den schlechtesten Gag der Welt so genial performen, dass die Leute am Boden liegen, du kannst aber auch den besten Gag so kacke performen. Bei euch ist es halt, bei euch ist es Papier, eure Welt ist das Papier und unsere Welt ist halt die Bühne. Und das ist so ein bisschen der Spagat, dass ihr vielleicht einen anderen Anspruch habt als jemand, der auf der Bühne steht. Wir haben ja auch keine Ahnung. Also wir standen ja noch nie auf einer Senderbühne, wir wissen ja nicht, wie hart es ist. Und natürlich sieht es immer einfach aus, wenn wir denken, aha, macht er da seinen Sailor Moon-Gag. Easy, er singt Blue Band, dann lacht es. Deswegen ist es natürlich immer schwer zu sehen, aber da musst du halt dann auch selber wissen, wo du hin bist. Mit der Frage beschäftige ich mich jeden Tag, also diese Selbstreflexion und was will ich eigentlich und diese Angst, ich glaube, Zukunftsangst hat, glaube ich, jeder in dem Geschäft, dass man sagt, vielleicht ist das mein Peak, vielleicht kommt ein Peak noch, du hast ja nichts gelernt, ja, ja gut, ja, fertig studiert, ach cool, was, ich habe Medienrecht und Kommunikationswissenschaft studiert, irgendwas mit Medien, naja, in der Tat, das ist das Klassische, aber ich wollte eigentlich, jetzt könnte ich einen Taxigag machen zum Beispiel, jetzt könnte ich einen Taxigag machen, mach ich nicht, das ist dein gutes Recht, als Medienjurist sage ich, das ist dein gutes Recht. Ich wollte eigentlich Medienanwalt werden. Medienanwalt? Ja, da hatte ich irgendwie Bock drauf. Fällt mir kein Gag zu ein. Nee, ne? Kennt ihr das, wenn man Medienanwalt sein will, dann aber Superstar, Comedian wird, der Groupies flach legt und sehr viel Koks, kennt ihr das? Legst du wirklich Groupies flach? Ich bin 26 Jahre alt, ich wohne in Köln, ich bin Single und ich gehe gerne aus. Den Rest müsst ihr zusammenpusten. Aber kommen die Groupies auf dich zu oder kommst du auf die Groupies auf? Also Groupies sind ja Frauen, die Backstage kommen und die man dann zu Hardrock-Mucke… Wie kommen die Backstage? Ja, also Backstage sind verdammte Creeps, die wie das Fenster raus. Aber kommt man da einfach rein? Oder sind die schon auch im Business irgendwo? Comedy ist jetzt auch nicht so das sexy Business, wo die aufgeklagten sind. Echt nicht? Nein, das ist ja nicht der Wu-Tang-Clan. Achso, achso. Also ich glaube, es gibt die… Also ich habe Backstage noch nie eine Frau, ausser meine Freundin, da zu der Zeit habe ich Backstage meine Freundin weggenagelt, mit ihr Sex gehabt, aber so Groupies irgendwie da weggauern, das habe ich noch nie gemacht. Im Nachtleben natürlich passiert das, das sind aber dann keine Groupies, das sind Leute, die man dann kennenlernt, aber das ist ja ein One-Night-Stand, wenn man irgendwie im Goldenschuss war oder im Sixpack. Bist also bist du, weil du eben meinst, du kannst auch nicht gut auf Leute zugehen, so in Party, so in so einem Privatleben, bist du deshalb auch dankbar, so berühmt zu sein, weil es einfacher fällt, Leute kennenzulernen? Ich hatte eine Pause, ich habe mir selber eine Pause gegründet im Sommer von sechs Wochen, dass ich gesagt habe, ich möchte sechs Wochen keinen einzigen Auftritt, keinen Termin, weil ich echt sehr, sehr kaputt war von den vielen KitKat-Drehen und Geld zählen und habe dann sechs Wochen keinen einzigen Drehtag und keine einzige Show gehabt und wollte eigentlich nach Bozen wandern gehen in die Berge, um mich selber irgendwie so ein bisschen zu finden und meine Mitte, bin aber tatsächlich dann in Köln geblieben und habe mich dann nach ein paar Wochen jeden Tag feiern, weil mir, und das habe ich dann später erst herausgefunden über mich selber, weil mir der Applaus fehlte. Also mir fehlte der Applaus, ja da ist er, ja und die Bewunderung, die du mit Liebe verwechselst. Ja und die Bestätigung halt auch, es ist was Objektives, klatschen als Objektiv. Das waren dann Entzugserscheinungen und deswegen bin ich ins Nachtleben, habe ich mir ins Nachtleben gestürzt und Leute kamen, du bist doch der von dem mit den neunzigern, mega geil, komm und das war dann quasi mein Applausersatz und das Dafür haben wir Twitter. Ja, Twitter ist für mich, also diese Leute, die auf Twitter so rum, also ich verstehe das, ich verstehe es nicht. Ne, es ist einfach, es ist auch eine Plattform, wo du Applaus abrufen hast. Da kriegen wir halt auch Applaus, wir kriegen halt Sterne und Likes, das ist halt unser Applaus, sobald wir halt überhaupt nicht unter Leute gehen, deswegen sind wir noch erbärmlicher auf gewisser Weise. Seid ihr Kellerkinder tatsächlich? Ja, geht so. Ja, absolut. Wart ihr beliebt in der Schule? Ja, hab ich schon gesagt, da hab ich in einer Band gespielt und so. Warte ich auch, geil. Wie hieß deine Band? Binky Sack Bu. Meine hieß Sprengstoff. Einfach mal Binky Sack Bu Google, ne? Ihr habt noch ein MySpace Account. Habt ihr noch ein MySpace Account? Mit sehr vielen animierten G. Und diesen geilen Drei-Phasen-Flammen. Was habt ihr für Musik gemacht? Punk-Rock. Wir auch. Wir haben so viele gemeinsame Nenner. Die alten Bands, die Classic-Rock-Bands, Sum 41, Blink-182, Green Day. Die alten, also. Die Classic-Rock-Tunes waren früher. Hier we go, wir haben Florentin komplett verloren. How You Remind Me. Du bist kein Rocker, oder? Nee, gar nicht. Florentin war jetzt, muss man sagen, der war vor ein paar Tagen in so einem Musik-Podcast, wo man seine eigenen Playlist mitnehmen kann und so, ganz geiles Konzept eigentlich, und er hört nur Schwachsinn, also wirklich so elektronisch, so billige Elektronik, wo man denkt, ja gut, das kann ich auch noch. Wo ich mir frage, warum hast du bei Komma die so Ansprüche und willst was hören, was du nicht selber könntest, hörst aber Musik, die du selber machen könntest. Hörst du zwölf Ton oder was hörst du? Nein, ich glaube, ich höre ganz normale Musik, aber für dich ist alles, was Elektro ist, automatisch irgendwie billig. Aber ja, hau mal ein paar Bands raus. Vielleicht kenne ich die, kennt man die nicht? Bonobo, Moderat, Quantic, sowas halt in der Richtung.
Quantic, ähnlich.
Geil, das ist wie so eine unangenehme Ecke, jetzt getrennt.
Guck mal, weil ich halt, als der Uncooler, der blieb an der Band, so, ich bin in der Band, hier an der Bühne, Punkrock und lege Groupies flach und so.
Naja.
Falls ihr Groupie seid, meldet euch.
Oh, das ist der obligatorische Wir-binden-unsere-Community-Miteinspruch. Zeig's mit einem Daumen nach oben.
Twitter-Hate ist für mich eine unfassbare... Also ich verstehe es. Wir sind Haten, die mir auch auf und sagen, das Tatort gucken, um es zu hassen. Ich verstehe es nicht. Auch Lanz, wenn Lanz immer so Hashtag Lanz klimpert und jetzt klimpert der auch noch... Aber es ist halt auch ein Zugehörigkeitsgefühl. Man trifft sich auf Twitter, man hält sich in der Hand und man hasst einen gemeinsamen Feind. Aber ist das nicht, also ich möchte jetzt nicht mit Küchenpsychologie daherkommen, aber ist das nicht absolut offensichtlich, dass die eigene Unzufriedenheit viel lauter spricht als eigentlich die coole Metaebene, ich mache irgendwas fertig? Also ich finde, wie unzufrieden, also wenn mir was nicht gefällt, dann befasse ich mich nicht damit.
Wenn ich einen Film scheisse finde, dann sageällt, dann befasse ich mich nicht damit.
Wenn ich einen Film scheiße finde, dann sage ich, oh, der Film fand ich irgendwie nicht so gut, ich habe den das ausgemacht, ich gehe noch. Oder wenn ich einen Comedian sehe, online oder bei Tera Total, dann sage ich, oh, wer ist das denn, oh, den finde ich aber scheiße, okay, Laptop auf, wie heißt der, Luke Mockridge, oh, falsch geschrieben, nee, also, ah, da ist er, cool. So, da poste ich jetzt mal was, oh du blöder Hurensohn, ich hasse dich, du bist un... So, was ist das für ein Gedan... was für eine Synapsenkette an kranken Bullshit ist das?
Ja, die Kritik ist ja gut, aber das ist ja Hass.
Also was man so äußert, was man nicht mag, finde ich schon auch sinnvoll.
Aber nicht um Hass und nur um ihn zu verletzen.
Wenn jemand sagt, ich fand das jetzt nicht so lustig, dann sage ich, okay, das ist okay. Schmeiß den Gag raus. Ja, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne das jetzt nicht so lustig, dann sage ich, okay, das ist okay. Schmeist den Gag raus. Aber den Appelgag raus, ja. Das ist ja auch das Tolle, dass wir was machen, was so nicht messbar ist. Aber es nervt auch manchmal, wenn man versucht, sich zu verbessern. Ja, es überfordert einen, ja. Es überfordert einen. Deswegen denkt man dann viel nach. Deswegen gibt es einen wunderschönen Satz, du bist nur so gut wie dein letzter Auftritt. So, jetzt sind wir einen Punkt erreicht. Jetzt könnte man gut auffallen. Wir weinen. Jetzt könnte man wirklich auffallen. Ja. Warum? Wir können auch weiter labern. Wir hoffen, dass das nicht der letzte Auftritt war und dass du nicht auf Twitter gehatet wirst. Ey, vielen Dank, dass du da warst. Wir waren uns natürlich auch nicht sicher, ob du kommen würdest, ob du da überhaupt Bock drauf hast, ob du Zeit hast. Es war einfach ein Lukes Woche-Prink. Und da ist die Kamera, und da. Und über die Garsche haben wir noch nicht geredet. Big Surprise! Paulina, wo bist du? Aber schon eine Angst von dir, nicht verarscht zu werden, oder? Ich habe eine tierische Angst. Aber es ist keine rationale Angst, einfach nur so eine Narzissmusangst. Wahrscheinlich. Wahrscheinlich wäre es schlimmer, wenn du nie verst. Wahrscheinlich. Ich habe ja auf Facebook gepostet, dass ich mich sehr freue, für den Deutschen Comedypreis nominiert zu sein mit Lukes Woche als beste Personality Show gegen Zirkus Halligalli, Neo Magazin Royal, Pussy Terror TV und Kaya-Jana. Und in dem Absatz danach habe ich geschrieben, es ist mir eine Ehre, mit diesen Menschen nominiert zu sein, zu denen ich hochschaue. Und ich hoffe, dass ich mit ihnen anstoßen darf und dass sie mich in ihren elitären Kreis der TV-Unterhaltung einnehmen. Und da ist auch so ein bisschen, naja, in dem Satz schwimmt ja auch viel mit, dass ich eigentlich mitspielen möchte. Wir haben den Anfang gemacht, wir haben nicht in unsere Hallen gelassen, die es nicht unsere sind, die wir uns einfach gekreilt haben, weil wir irgendwie keinen anderen Raum haben. Und vielleicht, wer nächste Woche Monsanto anruft und fragt, ob du Währung machen willst, dann überleg vielleicht nochmal und sag, will ich zu Monsanto gehören oder zu Jan Böhmermann? Aber, also erstmal vielen Dank für die Einladung, ich finde das sehr, und in dem Video sage ich das, glaube ich, oder? In dem Video habe ich es auch, glaube ich, gesagt, in dem besoffenen Video, dass ich ein Sokbrochen oder so ist. Ich glaube, da hast du Nightwash eingeladen, du hast sämtliche Sachen in Sokbrochen.
Oh Gott, das war sehr peinlich. Es war sehr peinlich, oder?
Du kamst supergut weg. Okay, das ist gut.
Ich bin der Typ, der sich anschleicht wie ein Creepy und dann am Ende noch nicht lacht.
Wie ein Creep, wie ein Creep. Das sind die schlimmsten eigentlich.
Ja, das war natürlich mein Abwehrsystem-Moment, zu sagen, ich weiß nicht was, weil ich kannte dich natürlich als Beef-Träger, als deine unglaublichen Auftritte, auch deinen IMDB-Eintrag kenne ich und deinen Wikipedia-Artikel in der Ich-Form geschrieben, die habe ich alles gelesen. Das ist kein schlechter Gag. Das ist nicht schlechter. Muss man loben machen. Für spontan gar nicht schlecht. Deswegen war meine Abwehrreaktion zu sagen, if you can't beat him, join him. Ich wusste nicht, was vielleicht, wer hat der Echt Schiss? Ist das jetzt Neo, ist das Böhm? Deswegen Welt umarmen, positiv der Welt. Ich glaube, es ist bei solchen Situationen auch nicht schwer, gut davonzukommen, so verarscht Situationen, oder? Also ich meine, oder? Also ich glaube, wenn man nicht komplett irgendwie ein Arschloch ist, dann ist es auch nicht schwer, da gut wegzukommen, wenn man dann einfach, vor allem, also alle, die ver verarscht werden, haben davor immer gesagt, so ich würde mich nicht verarschen lassen, ich würde es sofort merken und so. Und deswegen denkt man immer in der Situation auch, ich würde mich auch nicht verarschen lassen, aber ich weiss gar nicht. Also hältst du dich für so ein unberechenbares Arschloch, dass du Angst hast, dass wenn du mal irgendwie auf dem falschen Fuss erwischt wirst und gefilmt wirst in einer Situation, in der du nicht gefilmt werden willst, dass du dann schlecht wegkommst? Äh, nee, das nicht. Aber ich glaube, diese Angst permanent irgendwie, das ist ja auch, ich glaube, vielleicht hat das auch damit zu tun, dass ich jetzt beobachtet werde, dass ich nicht durch, also dass ich in Köln laufe und Selfie hier, Selfie da und Leute irgendwie gucken und versteckt Fotos machen, also man ist irgendwie so immer. Was auch gruselig ist. Ja, das ist das Schlimme. Das ist wirklich gut. Hat auch mal einer von uns, hat einer mal ihn erkannt als Beefträger und ich bin daneben gegangen und habe ein Foto von uns auf Twitter entdeckt, was ein mega komisches Gefühl war. Ja, das ist verschrecklich. Luke Mockridge gesehen, Hashtag auf Instagram. Boah, aber das ist so... Aber vor allem, das Problem ist, das sind ja keine Hater, das sind ja Fans. Aber die raffen trotzdem nicht, dass es halt einfach mega uncool ist, wenn du von dir ein Bild siehst und denkst, ah, okay, davon wusste ich jetzt nichts. So, dass sie das auch nicht verstehen, dass man das eigentlich nicht macht. Ich habe jeder Künstler so ein bisschen Angst, um jetzt auf die Frage zurückzukommen, dass das sein Kartenhaus zusammenbricht, weil das ein so unmessbarer Grad ist, den wir da jede Woche oder jeden Tag auf der Bildung. Das ist nicht wie ein Tischler, der einen Tisch macht und dann steht der Tisch, sondern irgendwie diese Angst, okay, irgendwann kommt mir einer drauf, dass ich eigentlich gar nichts kann.
Und dann macht einer so, ich schüchte ein Typ auf der Party bin, der hierher steht.
Und irgendwann fällt diese Karte und dann stehe ich da und dann so, fuck.
Sie merken, dass alle meine Gags von Neingag geklaut sind.
Ja, absolut, ja, ja. Neingag ist fantastisch. Neingag ist super.
Zehn Minuten vor dem Auftritt, Memes, zack, zack, zack.
Memes oder Memes?
Ich glaube, Mimi heisst es.
Mimi? Ja, Mimi. Mimi.eme. Meme. Meme. So heißt Französisch. Ja, nochmal lange. Ja, danke für die Einladung und für den Booster und für die Kit Cards. Habt ihr die wirklich gekauft? Wer haben die wirklich gekauft? Nein, die haben wir nicht gekauft. Wovor sollen die sonst haben? Die haben mit dem Flüchtling geklaut. Ja, cool, fantastisch. Wir hätten ja gar nicht gedacht, dass du so ein cooler Typ bist eigentlich, irgendwie. Steht das da drin? Ich lese die Abmoderation vor. Vielen Dank für das Gespräch.
Man, da war ja viel dabei. Der hat mich echt gefreut, ja. Sehr viel Gutes dabei, sehr viel angeboten. Ne, sehr cool, dass du das mal so oft mit dir aufhören.
Ich glaube, viele, die den Sendungszitel Luke Morgens gesehen haben, denken erstmal nicht, dass du bei uns zu Gast bist, weil das, glaube ich, eine Paarung ist, die man nicht so erwarten würde. Aber ich hoffe, dass sie positiv überrascht wurden. Das ist echt interessant, wie die Leute das jetzt hier wahrnehmen. Ich bin auch sehr gespannt. Wir sind sehr, wir wurden sehr angegangen für das Interview mit Maxi Stettenbauer. Ja, weil ihr wurdet angegangen, es war sehr awkward. Wir aber eher auch. Es war mega awkward. Beide wurden angegangen. Da haben wir auch noch nicht drüber gesprochen, so richtig. Aber es ist schon so ein bisschen der...
Er hat eben gesagt, es war sehr awkward.
Was war denn genau... Also wir fragen uns ja auch, aber wir hatten auch Angst, dass es...
Okay, Haar-Moderation Nummer drei, komm gleich.
Es ist egal, dass wir bei dir ähnlich versagen wie bei ihm.
Die Angst hattet ihr? Ja, klar, natürlich.
Wart ihr nervös jetzt vor dem Ding hier heute?
Ja, klar. Echt? Ja, natürlich.
Ja, vor allem der Aufbau ist ja schon so lange, weißt du, schon seit Wochen schreiben wir irgendwie da nochmal verschoben. Wir sind ein kleiner Willi-Podcast, nur das fucking Luke Mockridge, der die Lexis Arena fügt. Ach, hör auf. Ne, und wir hatten tatsächlich auch schon ein bisschen so die Angst, dass wir uns auch falsch verkaufen, dass wir uns die komplett anbiedern und so. Und wir haben in vorigen Podcast-Folgen, das können wir auch sagen, kritisch über dich geredet, haben wir gesagt, so von wegen, das ist so die Art von Comedy so leicht, irgendwie bla bla, mal irgendwie ein paar Studentinnen irgendwie ins Boot holen, so, dass es nicht unbedingt unseres ist, so, und es war mir persönlich auch wichtig, dass ich dir das auch sage, so, dass ich das nicht alles so ganz cool finde, weil ich mich sonst unehrlich gefühlt hätte, dir gegenüber, dir zu vergöttern und dir zu sagen, dass ich manche Sachen nicht cool finde, deswegen war da auch so ein bisschen sein eigenes Standing so ein bisschen zu verteidigen wichtig. Aber nee, klar, auf jeden Fall, wir haben nicht immer Gäste und wir treffen generell sehr wenige Menschen. Und deswegen ist das auch sehr interessant. Absolut. Sehr interessant, es gibt ja Joko und Klaas, für wen Joko und Klaas zu Mainstream ist, der hört Schulz und Böhmermann, und für wen Schulz und Böhmermann zu Mainstream ist, der, der hört euch.
Möglicherweise tatsächlich, das ist so das Fählersystem so unten. Luke Mockridge sagt über sie, wer ist das? So was. Wäre besser, wenn du Podcast-Ufo gesagt hättest und nicht euch, aber also falls du es nochmal sagen willst. Wie habe ich nochmal angefangen? Man kann ja noch weiter oben anfangen. Wer Adam und Eva zu Mainstream findet, der guckt sich Gottschalk und Jauch an.
Wer Gottschalk und Jauch an.
Wer Gottschalk und Jauch nicht mag, der guckt sich Joko und Klaas an.
Wem Joko und Klaas zu Mainstreamig sind, der guckt Olli Schulz und Jan Böhmermann.
Jetzt kannst du meine Hose aufmachen.
Und wem das auch noch viel zu Mainstreamig ist, der hört das Podcast an.
Vielen Dank, Tim Gorgels.
Vielen Dank.
Tschüss. der das podcast vielen dank dem goggen